Yes,
and we're live.
Welcome back,
Mr Wood.
Thanks for having me buddy.
It could.
It's been a wild year for people who
don't know.
Michael was a former,
um,
you were.
Well,
you never really a former marine,
right?
Isn't that one of those things where
you're a marine,
you stay marine.
I don't quite buy that.
If I,
if I would have stayed maybe,
but uh,
for the Marines who agree with that.
Okay.
You were
marine,
a former sergeant in the Baltimore
Police Department and he came on the
podcast a while back and expose some
pretty eyeopening information about how
the whole system sort of works in this
sort of a kind of a closed loop in,
in Baltimore where the same
neighborhoods are having the same kind
of crime in the same sort of scenarios
over and over again.
And that was a really important podcasts
for me and it was really important
podcast for a lot of people that listen
to it because they got exposed to the
inner workings of police departments by
someone who's,
you know,
I was really happy how honest you were
about all of it.
About the thrill of chasing people and
uh,
all of all the cool stuff about it and
we scheduled this podcast quite a while
ago and it's kind of crazy that you're
coming in the weekend after these insane
shootings in Orlando and I'm,
I'm absolutely not happy that that
happened,
but I'm happy.
Is happy as I could be that your here
while this is all going down and we get
to kind of talk about
these,
these moments,
these insane moments that happen.
It seems like every few months or so,
some new insane moment happens where
some person,
usually a man blows a fuse and winds up
killing a ton of people.
I don't know what,
if anything,
and I'm hoping maybe you'll have some
insight.
What if anything could ever be done to
stop something like this?
Well,
this is where we get into the Mike
Rhodes a dirty liberal thing and we're
going to start talking about gun control
because I don't know what else we can
talk about.
Your only other option is to continue a
cycle of more and more force upon one
another.
So what we know for sure without a doubt
that the path we're on,
it is only a matter of time before this
record is broken.
Right?
So what we're doing will result in that,
but we have this anti-intellectualism in
America that just won't take that
evidence and apply it to what we know is
going to be the end result like it.
We have countries that have done gun
control,
they don't have mass shootings,
we have mass shootings literally on the
daily in America.
You just don't hear about them all.
So when a mass shooting is generally
characterized three or four more
casually,
something like that.
But this happens every day in the cities
doesn't really.
Yeah.
You don't hear about it when it's a
backyard barbecue shooting in the right.
Yeah.
So that you can think of that.
Um,
a lot of people don't categorize those
as mass shootings because think of mass
shootings is someone going into a
crowded place and killing a bunch of
civilians or innocent people I should
say.
Whereas they think of those kinds of
shootings in the hood as rival gangs,
people competing over drug dealing
territory.
Things along those lines,
which is another point because you were
running for you,
you wanted to be the head of police of
Chicago.
Is that still going on?
No,
I mean they certainly,
uh,
the corruption went in and uh,
so we can tell that story real quick.
What they did is they did a national
search,
so the laws in Chicago said that this
appointed police board has to do a
nationwide search and then they give
three names to the mayor.
The mayor investigates those people and
then chooses one.
So I predicted they weren't going to go
with me.
I'm too far ahead still that no one's
really ready to take that bite yet,
but it's still something we could have
talked about and they would have had the
opportunity.
I figured they would pick that,
uh,
that I figured they'd pick a black guy
who was educated and not from Chicago.
That was my prediction.
And that's who the police board did
choose.
They chose a guy from Atlanta who fit
that bill to the t.
He was going to be
the black guy that represents the police
department but still totes their line.
I'm thinking of a word that everybody
knows and I'm just not saying it so you
can all pick up on what I'm suggesting.
You're saying uncle Tom and people have
an uncle Tom,
but he's a nice guy,
so if you have an uncle and his name's
Tom,
don't worry about it.
So that's what they're gonna.
Look for something that will visually
seems satisfying.
I see instructionally be exactly the
same.
So they chose that guy and the mayor
still said,
yeah,
I don't know what that guy I want you
was this guy that didn't even apply and
that skews the commissioner.
So who is this guy that didn't imply he
was a couple of ranks down.
I'm already in the agency.
He is a.
He said that he has never seen
misconduct or corruption in the Chicago
Police Department and his entire 20 some
year career,
he is intimately tied into a cheating
scandal,
a promotional test.
Another thing that you could solve
easily.
So his friends like wife or something
got number one,
the lieutenant's test,
which is extremely a qualifying.
So say.
And as soon as the information comes
down that he actually was the one that
was developing the tests,
had the answers,
and then she gets this super high score
out of nowhere is when everybody says,
oh,
come on,
we've seen this before,
we know what it is,
so you can solve it.
You could retest them.
Right.
And see who does it.
But at first of course not.
So they're not going to do that.
Did they have any interest in exposing
thing?
So if I'm going to come in there and I'm
going to say,
all right,
that's it.
We're going to be transparent,
I don't think there.
Okay.
So now when you say that you were a
little too far ahead,
what do you mean by that?
Well,
it seems the people of a city or of any
area have to be pushed hard enough to,
to have that change.
Like they have to have that breaking
point where they say that's it.
We're going to do something different.
Because what I really push is for
civilian controlled policing.
I want you guys to tell me what what
should be done,
which is a huge drop in power,
so that's.
That would require a mayor that's
willing to give in to the people that
have pushed hard enough to say,
look,
I'm going to relinquish control of my
essential armed wing and I'm going to
give it to the people,
and so it's been done before.
Not that I'm aware of.
Not In America.
It's certainly hasn't.
So who's going to be the city that takes
that leap?
It has to come.
It has to.
We all know it,
so it's a matter of fact.
Well,
what they've tried to do in some areas
like in New Jersey in particular,
is force these people to integrate more
into the community,
make them walk the beat,
which is not like,
you don't hear about that anymore.
Now everyone's in a car and you're
driving around this closed up vehicle.
Whereas before everybody was walking
around and you were sort of like,
oh,
there's officer Mike,
you know,
he's a part of the community and they
get it.
It became normal to see these people,
they develop friendships with the people
that were in their neighborhood that
they were patrolling and it's sort of
ingrained.
She hated them more.
I think having a bunch of people that
you don't know,
patrolling your streets with guns in a
car just driving around and you know,
hardly ever getting out and
they're arresting somebody.
That's a little odd,
right?
Well yeah,
but I don't see that the foot patrol is
the solution to that because what they
do is they put a facade on it so they
make it look like foot patrol,
but it still has his essential
underpinnings of,
of being motivated to go and make
arrests and to get the stats.
So I did four patrol for like six months
and that's what it was.
It was just being thrown into get drug
arrests.
I didn't know anybody or meet anybody.
It was still those same pushing to get
somebody,
put them in a,
in a prison cell,
do the paperwork,
go back out and do it again.
So what we really need is to change the
incentives and disincentives so that no
matter what the role,
we're still going towards that objective
that actually serves you.
Right?
I had Dave Smith and the other day,
excuse me,
I'm Dave Smith,
who is a hilarious standup comedian and
he's also a on this podcast called
Legion of skanks and he's a libertarian,
very smart guy,
but he was,
he was bringing up a point about New
York after the shootings in New York
where a bunch of cops had gotten shot.
Um,
um,
there was this sort of a cool off period
where they had just stopped arresting
people for Bullshit and the bullshit
arrests,
like loose cigarettes,
things along those lines just dropped
substantially.
And people were really excited about
that.
They were like,
look,
this is like a good step.
Like,
this is really how it should be.
The police shouldn't be glorified
revenue collectors just arresting people
for the taxes last on loose cigarettes.
And that's what killed Eric Gardner.
Right?
Precisely.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's disgusting.
It's not,
it's not policing because not hurting
anybody.
Policing should be protecting and
serving.
Right.
I'm really glad that you brought up that
instance in New York,
so what that is is direct evidence
against what the head of the FBI has
said Komi who's coming in these pushing
this ferguson effect,
right?
So the idea around there saying,
oh,
we have crime going up in these
different neighborhoods because there's
this ferguson effect that the cops are
laying back so they're not being as
proactive and because they're not being
as proactive,
then they're not locking people up.
So.
So stats are going up and we know that
if you have a theory and there's one
situation that says your theories
complete crap when your theory theories
complete crap,
and that's what New York was.
So New York,
they step back and they want it to be
like,
oh,
look how much you need us.
And didn't show that the stats showed
lower crime.
They had less calls for service.
Everybody was happier with what was
going on because that is,
we want to say that policing should
prevent things and it's just not
possible.
Police are there to clean things up and
to investigate after the fact.
Every arrest should be viewed as a
failure of the system.
We shouldn't praise and arrest.
That is when we failed.
That's an interesting way of looking at
it.
I think
another way to look at it that's maybe
more a more common ground is your
fucking with people.
When you're.
When you're around them all the time and
you're like,
what's going on over there?
Boys?
You know like that kind of shit.
You're fucking with them.
You create intention.
Intention creates arguments.
It creates crime.
It creates resentment.
It creates anger.
All those things contribute to crime 100
percent and when you fuck with people
over loose cigarettes or any sort of
nonsense,
petty crime that nobody gives a shit
about.
That kind of stuff isn't.
It's not good for anybody.
It's not good for the relationship that
police have with citizens.
It's not good for the perception of the
citizens of,
of the way they view the police.
You make some view the police as these,
these thugs
which citizens though a significant
amount and the citizens in this country
very much like that.
The fact that police do that well did
they don't live there,
right?
But if they were poor and they lived in
those communities,
they wouldn't feel like you always do
this.
You hit on these big issues because
you're just like,
well wait,
this is obvious.
It's right in front of our face and what
they're doing is they are funded and you
know,
so you have a mayor in Baltimore,
the mayor directs the police
department's a way,
no matter what city you're in,
and what that person is doing is they're
serving those,
those rich people,
they're serving,
uh,
the mass voters of the area who just had
that mentality still that they want
those animals caged in sentiment and to
keep them there.
So as long as it doesn't affect us,
then who cares?
Right.
That's really what you're hitting on
there is that they,
I don't know that more of this country
doesn't want our police to be that way.
I think they are happy about it.
I think you're probably right,
but I think they're misinformed and I
think they have this,
this incorrect understanding of how that
affects the people that these cops are
interacting with and that that it
actually does probably create more crime
and then on top of that,
I think there's also the problem with
those people that are in those poor
communities could just as easily be Uri,
if we were born into those situations
and we were talking about giving people
an opportunity to get out,
given people a possibility to get out
and do better and improve their
situation,
their standing in life,
well,
if they're getting fucked with all the
time,
that's not going to happen.
If they're in a terrible poverty laden
crime laden community,
good luck with that.
Good luck getting out of that.
It becomes almost insurmountable and I
think it's real convenient for people to
be outside of that and and look at those
folks and go,
well,
those people need to stop doing crime.
What you need to do is just lock them
all up.
Well,
that doesn't seem to make sense.
It seems much more likely that the best
way to handle that is to lock them up
less and to sort of somehow or another
try to calm that area down and I don't
know how you would do it.
I mean,
whether it's through some universal
basic income idea,
which I've been paying a lot of
attention to that lately and trying to
explore those ideas and see if I can
read my own,
call me a socialist and you're talking
about minimum.
It wasn't my idea.
It was.
It was an idea that Eddie Huang brought
up on the podcast and I initially
laughed at him.
I was like,
nobody's going to fucking go for that.
And then I started reading some articles
on it and I started thinking about it
and financially the issue is where's
that money come from?
And you're obviously gonna.
It's a shit ton of money that's going to
have to somehow or another come out of
something else.
And I'm not A.
I'm not a financial person.
I don't understand the economy.
I'm not an economist so I'm not the
person to do the numbers,
but when I think about it like
objectively
as far as from a social stance,
when people have less problems,
when bills are paid easier,
when they're more relaxed as far as like
where food's coming from,
where you know,
what basic needs are covered,
they're less likely to commit crime.
So it just makes sense that you would
have to spend less money on law
enforcement,
less money on prisons,
less money on jails,
and that perhaps that could translate.
There was a great article written by,
see if you could find A.
Jamie's is some prominent libertarian
who wrote this piece about universal
basic income is the idea is essentially
giving people $13,000 a year that if you
give Americans through essentially a
thousand bucks plus a month and that if
you did that,
you would take care of a shitload of
problems that we have in inner cities
and crime and all this.
And he a sort of outlined it and made a,
a,
a pretty interesting case for this idea.
Um,
but of course you've got a lot of people
that want to go on and on about welfare
babies and,
and,
and people that are juking the system
and buying cigarettes with food stamps
and you know,
things along those lines,
but it's like this callous sort of
approach to dealing with really poor
people in really bad neighborhoods.
And one of the things that you brought
up about Baltimore that made it so
disturbing was that black people had to
buy houses in these areas.
They would not sell houses in certain
areas to black people.
And that this was like a law.
And this was actually written.
Dennis was not,
not like everybody conspired.
This was something that they actively
set out to do.
They,
the,
this idea of caging them,
keeping them in,
they,
they literally did that through
paperwork.
Right?
And that's a,
so things that you're talking about and
like that sociologists that has that
study,
we,
we know these things.
So what you're observing is things that
the scholarly community has known for a
long time and is trying to,
to get these things out there so that
people understand this.
It's not even a matter of how much is
this going to cost because we're already
spending the money that we're spending a
lot more this book,
this is why I brought it with me because
I just finished going through it.
It was just put out.
So this is by a Johns Hopkins researcher
and Stefanie Deluca who's a friend of
mine,
you know,
so everybody knows that I am saying it,
but she,
they did a study,
they followed Baltimore youth around for
well over a decade.
I think it was like 15,
16 years and their path that they go
through and part of that was it costs
$27,
billion dollars to America every single
year for disconnected youth.
So that's just youth that don't have a
drive and don't have a focus or how is
that,
um,
money?
How does it trickle down so they don't
chase things,
right?
So you get stuck in this,
this,
this idea
that you can't escape this neighborhood
because we have so many blockades in the
way.
There are stories that go through.
They track like a hundred and some
people,
parents having kids in these
neighborhoods.
And moving them out and what happened to
them and the two biggest pushers for the
success of these have any kid in these
cities was that they had an identity
project,
which means they're finding their
passion and what they're going to go
towards because they don't know these
passions.
They don't know that a photographer like
Devin Allen,
who a friend of mine in Baltimore can,
can come out and do things for their
community and can actually achieve that
dream.
So once they see it and it's possible
and you start taking the hurdles down,
like the hurdles of where they live and
the hurdles of the arrest for the bag of
weed or for,
like you said,
the,
the talking yourself into jail because
the cops messing with you every single
day and you're saturated with police in
these neighborhoods.
You start taking down these barriers and
these kids excel and it goes completely
against the narrative that we're hearing
that these kids don't have motivation
and they can't push out.
Eighty percent of these kids that grow
up in the city never touched the streets
or have anything to do with it.
They're getting high school degrees at
four or 500 percent.
The rate of their parents,
it's just that what we keep doing is we
keep getting them behind and they're
still fighting super hard,
but we're still throwing more and more
hurdles in their wet,
so the money that you're talking about
how much it costs for these disconnected
use.
This is all in prisons.
This isn't even phrase it.
What is.
This is just the lack of their product
productivity from achieving what they
can achieve and what it's costing us to
then take care of of what the fallout is
in that,
that,
that just that microcosm.
We're not throwing in locking up
everybody else.
We're not throwing in the parents.
We're not throwing in all this other
stuff.
Just youth that don't have a passion.
Well,
this is one of the subjects that come up
over and over again on this podcast
because I've always tried to figure out
what it is that keeps people from trying
to socially engineer these,
these environments and make them better
for the people that live there.
Like we're always concentrating on all
these other countries.
We're concentrating on helping
Afghanistan and rebuilding Iraq and all
the stuff that we do,
humanitarian efforts all over the world.
Right.
What about our own inner city?
I think they do.
I think they're misguided,
so what we end up doing is we have this
idea that we're rich and often white and
we're going to come in and we're going
to have the handout or we're going to
give them what we want.
We're going to show them the right way
and that's not the answer.
The answer is to ask what they want and
provide the structure and platform for
that to take place.
So when these smart people that haven't
been there,
they'll look at stats and they'll look
at the paperwork and they'll say,
oh,
we just need to move people out and
relocate them,
or we need to.
The idea was,
all right,
well we'll put them in this big tower
and we're have resources around them and
everything will be fine and we're making
sure they have their own police
department so everything will be will be
good,
but then the police started locking
everybody up and you just.
You get into that cycle again because
you're not giving the identity project
even to adults,
adults where you can say whether it's
comedy or whether it's photography or no
matter what,
you have to have that goal,
that vision because all they see is that
their future is in dealing or in a
prison cell and they keep being told
that if they do the right things they
can move on,
but when they do the right things are
sometimes good intentions have put up
the roadblocks that prevent them from
doing that.
So what but how do you.
You sort of engineer,
for lack of a better term,
a whole society.
Like how do you give them goals?
How do you,
how do you expose them to all these
possibilities
and how do you set up pass?
You just said the word expose.
They're isolated.
They don't know.
Right,
but how do you do that though?
I think social media is helping a ton so
they can see and interact with people
that are different from them and they
can see,
oh look,
this kid from New York,
he did get into this school and he has
this job now and now I can maybe go work
for his company or whatever it is.
They see these examples of success and
then they start to pick them up and
chase them and that's what these stats
and all this bookers showing that.
It's staggering how much effort these
kids are putting in to their goals.
It's just that we're actually setting up
the prevention of it by doing things
like,
oh,
okay.
We charge a black kid in the city.
You know,
you charge him.
He commits a homicide because he was
defending his sister from getting raped,
but when he gets a prison sentence,
we know that that prison sentence just
slams him.
But when it's a white kid from Sanford,
you know what happens.
So it's kind of this.
I don't want to push empathy all the
time,
but there is that,
that empathy angle,
but it's just kind of helping people get
where they want to get instead of
pushing them where you think they should
be.
They'll find their own paths.
It's like we treat poor people like
they're children and they're not.
They're poor people.
There's a dude who works at the comedy
store who was a criminal defense
attorney and he resigned.
He stopped doing it because he got tired
of his.
When he was bringing cases to trial.
If it was a white guy,
the white guy would get,
you know,
whatever,
six months for an identical crime,
a young black guy would get 10 years and
he was like,
you've got to.
Someone's got to tell me what the fuck
is going on here,
because all I'm looking at
is systematic racism.
I'm looking at institutional racism.
He was like,
this is just over and over and over
again.
I'm confronted by the same kind of
people,
the same age brackets,
but completely different types of
sentences.
And,
uh,
what's the mentality behind it?
And he said everybody wanted to just
bury their head head in the sand and he
couldn't do it anymore.
It was so strong.
I mean,
when the guy talks about he's like
smoking cigarettes and freaking out
because it was just a huge 10 years of
his life and it was just too much.
He couldn't do it anymore.
That kind of shit is almost
insurmountable when you.
You're living in that world and you are
one of those people that gets sent down
the river for 10 years for something
that you know,
if you were a white Irish kid,
you would get six months or you know,
a much lesser sentence.
That alone is got to be a gigantic
hurdle for someone living in these
environments.
And this is not saying that people
shouldn't be punished for crimes.
They definitely should be punished for
crimes.
But for sure about that,
they also should be punished.
Absolutely.
It should be our view for be our view.
Do you think they should do about
murder?
She punish them or just give him a hug?
It was certainly depend on the
situation,
but I can't help but keep coming back to
the fundamental idea that our criminal
justice system is based on punishment
like that.
It's not a moral system.
It's like the death penalty.
We know that these things don't work.
So now now do they get rights taken
away?
So what I would like to see is,
let's take for instance,
we know that it costs so-and-so
thousands of dollars a year to house.
Somebody thinks 24,000 depends on where
you are though.
So a college degree from an online
school that's accredited,
which we can all do easily right now
would cost way less than that.
So put them in a,
in a,
in a cell,
and you keep them around,
but you treat them like human beings.
You give them an identity,
a goal where they can achieve something
and they actually.
Because right now we send them into a
prison of punishment and what happens
when they come out,
they're in a worse situation.
So now we've created a greater criminal
than we had before.
So our goal is supposed to be some kind
of rehabilitation that this is a better
person when they leave than when they go
in.
But we have that in us.
We want these fuckers to pay.
Well,
certainly for murder,
I mean for the families of someone that
they victimized,
they don't want this person to come out
better.
Not even all victims feel that way
though,
you know,
and it,
it's so there are plenty of murder
victims who,
who their parents have gone and asked
for leniency for,
for the person,
or ask the not give him the death
penalty because that's pretty fucking
rare that it is.
Yes,
yes.
Most people want revenge,
but we have to look beyond that because
you know when,
when your sister gets in a fight and
killed your neighbor,
who's your friend or something like
that,
you're not asking for the death penalty.
Right?
Because it's close to you.
Well,
the others,
we do that to others.
We wouldn't do that to the ones we know
well,
threats to society,
those.
That's the real
issue with some people,
White,
black,
whatever.
Someone's associate,
associate pass some as a psycho.
They're a threat to society,
like I'm the guy who killed all those
people in the theater in Denver.
That's a psycho.
I mean that.
That guy needs to be locked up forever.
Right?
Okay.
You don't need to know about it.
Well,
what do you do about a person like that?
I mean,
how do you.
How do you take a person like that and
you give them goals in prison?
Do you try to give them an education
mean?
Obviously,
think about that.
He could become,
not not him obviously saying he doesn't
mental illness,
but somebody else you could educate them
why they're there and they can
contribute to literature and contribute
to science.
They can give back to some society in
some way.
Is that financially feasible?
How much more money would it take to
make prison a safer environment for
people that are locked up?
I mean were the idea is that we're
supposed to be protecting the rest of us
from these people that have committed
these awful crimes,
right?
Someone's committed rape,
someone's committed murder or armed
robbery.
We separate them from us because we
don't want them to victimize anymore
people.
Then goal number two is rehabilitation
and that goal is overwhelmingly a
failure.
Overwhelmingly,
if you look at the statistics,
if we sit in,
it's been attempted.
Yeah,
that's a good point.
I mean,
we'll do our,
I mean Rick Ross,
the guy that we've had on before,
the real rick Ross,
not the rapper guy.
Um,
he,
I mean he learned how to read and
literally figured out what was wrong
with his case in prison.
Do that though.
A lot of them won't give them any access
at some do.
So there are wardens out there that are
progressive and are thinking of these
things.
So that shouldn't really be on the
warden.
Honda should be some sort of a standard
nationwide,
what we should look at it as a culture,
as a society,
as a civilization and say,
hey,
you know,
what,
what should we be trying to do to try to
make these people better people?
Right?
And you do that when you arrest them
though.
So what we say now is when he goes and
shoots or when someone rapes,
we're not looking at it at that as that
failure.
So if you,
if you were running this business and an
asset,
a facet of your business failed,
then you would want to have an analysis
and you would want to say,
all right,
let's do a regression and figure out
what went wrong and you would want to
fix that for the next time.
But we don't do that.
We just go,
all right,
throw that one away and continue.
Path is normal.
We shouldn't be so focused when we
arrest somebody to figure out how we're
going to throw them away from the
longest.
We should be figuring out why it
happened so we can prevent it for the
next person.
But it doesn't seem like we actually
care about solving the crime.
We're just keeping these wheels turning.
So if you commit murder than I want to
know why.
I want to know the scenarios that led
you up to that because the only way that
I can actually prevent that is not
minority report.
It's finding out what that hurdle was.
That moment that you said,
fuck this.
And finding ways to prevent that as much
as possible or reduce it for other
people.
Lot of it must have to do with the
developmental period that you go through
when you're a young person and what
you're exposed to as a small
child.
I mean that stuff becomes so deeply
ingrained in a person's mind to try to
reverse that boy is so much harder than
to try to race someone correctly the
first time.
All that's in this book,
they talk about that is coming of age in
the other America that they talk about
these things where that's one of the
predictors is how much exposure to
violence that these kids have had when
they were going between the ages of zero
and 10,
and so when they got them out of the
city and they gave him opportunities
than they got exposed to less violence.
The really crazy thing in this study is
that we found out that the kids that
were in this city that didn't get help,
they also fought their way out.
Actually a higher rate.
So we did these nice things and we have
to tweak it,
but like are nice things that we did
actually didn't pan out in the same
results as kids that were just fighting
on their own.
So explain that.
Yeah,
yeah.
It's wild.
So they had these housing voucher
programs where they would.
The idea was to take people out of those
neighborhoods and put them into nicer
neighborhoods where they would be
exposed to less things.
They would have neighbors around that
that did things that was very beneficial
when,
when that happened,
but about an equal percentage of those
kids went back,
ended up being in the low income areas
and get involved in to the streets.
And then the ones that fought themselves
out on their own ended up at a higher,
slightly higher percentage actually
getting out and being exposed to less
because of their own individual efforts
and the control group trying to get out
of there.
So while it says that the programs need
some tweaking,
but it shows that it's counter narrative
that these kids aren't trying and that
they're not succeeding to get out.
Like they are pushing super hard to make
something of themselves and our cultural
idea is like,
oh look at these kids are not doing
anything.
They're just turning to drugs and
they're just dealing and surprisingly
they're not.
It is a 12 percent of the kids raised in
Baltimore in this study ever spent and
these are in the worst neighborhoods.
It's east and West Baltimore ever spent
a moment on the streets doing any
criminal activity.
Twelve percent staggering.
I'm going to have shocked.
I feel dumb because I did the same
things like Yo.
So they're exposed to.
Right,
but it's not.
They're fighting out like crazy and
we're the ones stopping them from coming
to fruition.
Well not US society.
We're responsible,
right?
Like so what are we mean?
Here's the thing.
It's like how much effort is actually
being done to try to fix this?
I mean how many people are actually
thinking about it?
How much money is actually being spent
to try to fix this?
It seems like there's so many problems
in the world that to concentrate on bad
neighborhoods or crime ridden
neighborhoods,
it's so low on the list of things.
The world's worried about.
The polarized caps are melting.
Polar bears are drowning,
you know,
there's so much shit we're worried about
on top of that.
They're trying hard as hell to keep it
the way it is though and was trying
hard.
Governments are in Baltimore
for example,
there's this,
this patent,
that thing that I'm a professor from
Morgan state.
Lawrence Brown is really into this and
tracks it all down,
but there is a white l,
we call it the White Allen Baltimore.
It goes down through the rich
neighborhood and comes across to the
other rich neighborhoods by the bay and
then there's the black butterfly which
comes off to the sides East and West
Baltimore and it looks like butterfly
wings dispersing out poverty and black
people in the city and what this is in
every single aspect that you're going to
find.
Where that.
Where the money goes for schools.
Where are the bus routes are?
Where the free buses,
like the white neighborhoods have a free
bus and the black neighborhoods have to
pay for their bus.
Yes.
So we have all these things that no
matter what you think of this white out
and this black butterfly come to
fruition.
I'm on where resources are allocated and
what problems are.
How is that possible that white people
don't have to pay for the bus and the
black people do.
That seems ridiculous when you want me
to tell you that they,
it's the neighborhood because the
neighborhoods,
you know,
so they're not serving the white people.
They're serving those upper class
neighborhood.
But is it a,
is it a tax issue?
Is it a property tax issue where they
spent money for the buses?
All Baltimore city.
So all the money.
So how the fuck could they justify that
they,
they just do it and nobody cares.
I mean it's,
it's so people should follow them.
It's at be more dark on twitter.
He,
he lays this out in so many different
avenues.
You,
you just,
you have to be willfully ignorant to not
realize that this is going on at Bemer
doc.
Okay,
that's,
that's insane.
Now how much of it is dealing with a
prison guard unions and police unions
that are trying to keep business as
usual because that keeps people employed
or that's a significant portion and
you're seeing that with the NRA and
you're seeing that with the police
unions and like you said,
the correctional unions were and like
see,
even them,
they don't have these bad intentions.
What they have is job preservation
comes back to those incentives and
disincentives,
so they're fighting for their job and
that's all they're thinking.
Well,
we want jobs,
we want safer conditions.
I want to make sure that this is a big
company that blows up,
so they're gonna put their money towards
politicians that support them and that's
just the way it goes this way.
It's always been,
as long as we have money in politics,
you can't get away from that.
Well,
the most transparent example that is
marijuana that we've shown time and time
and again with a million different
studies that marijuana is not dangerous
or if it is dangerous.
The danger that it poses is so minimal.
It's so small that consenting adults
should be able to do whatever the fuck
they want with it and yet prison guard
unions and police unions still lobby to
keep the drug laws exactly the same way
they are because that ensures that
you're gonna need a certain amount of
guards.
You're going to need a certain amount of
police officers.
That's counterintuitive.
It being that's dangerous for society
because that sets up this us versus them
mentality where it doesn't need to be
where you're telling people there's a
certain forbidden plant that they're not
allowed to use.
We've decided this,
we're going to keep it this way even
though it's completely illogical,
even though we know the history of it
and we're going to do it simply because
people want to keep their jobs instead
of trying to figure out what other jobs
these people can do like shouldn't there
be a way you could take some of these
people that are prison guards or police
officers and give them a job with a
commensurate income that's involved in
helping communities.
Something positive,
something setting up community programs.
I mean how many guys that are cops who
were also into martial arts or fitness
or into something else,
or you know,
anything where they could teach people
in these communities,
set up community centers and give people
high paying jobs to establish really
good environments for development and
for growing and give people a chance to
be exposed to maybe one of these things
that could be these paths that you were
talking about.
Yeah,
I mean I have.
Obviously I'm gonna have zero objections
to that.
I mean that that's a great way of going
about it and cannabis is obviously the
shining example of complete illogic.
They just did a new study where they
tracked people for 30 years.
You know what health problems they
found,
what ginger vidas bad breath.
They just didn't brush her teeth.
The hippies didn't brush their soki
breath.
Hippies study people said they said the
same thing,
but that probably goes because segment
of the population.
Yeah,
and it doesn't have anything to do with
the cannabis.
That's hilarious.
So we know without a doubt that,
that that's the case.
But what we can do,
so say you still want to do that and we
only have to change them that far to,
to get them away from the drug where
even though that's,
that's probably the biggest chunk that's
fucking everything up is the drug war.
But if we spend that money,
instead of incarcerating them,
we can spend the money in education.
So for every million dollars that spent
fighting the drug war on the supply
side,
there's a 100 kilogram reduction of,
of supply.
So,
uh,
if,
if you have the kilograms of cocaine
coming over the border,
if you fight it with force,
you fight the supply side,
then you get a 10 gram per kilogram
reduction.
But if you spend that same million
dollars on the demand side educating
people,
you have a reduction of 100 kilograms.
Whoa.
So we,
that's,
where's this from?
I don't know.
Somebody can look it up.
It's really easy to find it right away.
That's very logical and it makes sense
to me.
So we know that if you just educate
people and tobacco is the shining
example of that is tobacco rates have
gone down like crazy.
Now let's take the hair gardner
situation out of that.
The large part of that has been because
of education.
So you educate people out of drugs,
educate people,
you know,
like they say all the time.
If,
if heroin is on Amazon right now to you
order it.
No,
I don't know how to
write.
I don't know about Jamie and Tara when
freak.
He loves it.
He gets a bunch of different styles and
mixes them up.
So it's prohibition.
That messes us up.
Yeah.
And we know that.
And when you have prohibition,
you are not determining what happens to
the drugs.
All you're doing is determining who is
distributing the drugs because they will
be distributed.
The question is,
is it the government and I e the people
doing the distribution or is it the
black market,
the gangs in the mafia?
Well,
as long as it's under prohibition,
it's the black market and the gangs in
the Mafia.
We,
we literally know this.
There's nothing to discuss.
And yet we continue with this anti
intellectual asm and denial at that.
That's kind of,
it runs throughout our society in
America.
Speaking about the guns,
you know,
we're dealing with the same thing where
it's just constant.
We have evidence we can prove things
empirically and we still continue to do
the opposite for for reasons I just
can't get my mind wrapped around lake.
It's were I feel like I'm fighting
denial and it's been like a year that I
fighting this denial and talking on
radio shows constantly.
But yet,
you know,
a couple months ago we pull up the
Internet and the FBI director is pushing
the ferguson effect and it's just like
fuck,
like how do we get past this?
Well,
I think that we're dealing with two
completely different subjects,
right?
The gun control subject is a very
different subject than trying to figure
out how to elevate people in bad
neighborhoods.
The gun control subject is,
you know,
if you look at the statistics of how
many Americans have guns,
how many rounds of ammunition there are,
how many armed people there are in this
country.
And then you look at how many crimes
there are,
how many gun shootings there are.
It's relatively small,
very small.
We're dealing with massive numbers of
people.
Yeah,
I mean if you.
There's $3 million,
okay.
There's $300,
million plus people in this country.
So if you look at this,
this blip on the map where every few
months someone goes fucking crazy and
killed a bunch of people.
If we really had a an armed problem in
this country,
the logic that the anti gun control
people use would be that you would see
way more shootings and you would see
them all the time.
If we really had a gun control problem,
you have so many armed people.
If it was a real issue,
but the issue would they try to say,
and I'm not picking the team here,
but what they try to say is that what
we're dealing with,
just massive numbers of people,
massive numbers of people.
The number $300 million is so hard for
the average person like you were.
I to wrap our head around what that
means in terms of the volume,
the sheer volume of people and how many
guns are out there.
This has many guns,
more guns,
and there are people in this country
which is even more insane,
and the
the people that own these guns for the
most part are law abiding citizens that
don't do anything wrong.
Why take away their rights?
Because some dude like this asshole in
Orlando goes fucking crazy and kills 50
gay people exist that have a couple of
premises there and one of them was that
they have a right to that weapon.
Right?
Which I'm going to argue to the end of
the day that they don't.
Okay.
The second amendment is clear.
Well regulated militia.
It's literally clear.
It says it in black and white,
well regulated militia and even if we go
to bear arms,
sure.
Right.
Even if we go past that,
forget that I'm not a big fan of the
constitution and leaning on it because
the world is changed dramatically.
We're in a whole new situation.
Rethink with the evidence that we have
now.
Let's not rely on the document that's on
parchment somewhere decaying,
right?
So written with a feather.
That's why they made it amendable.
So the first thing is that they have
that right?
I don't think they have the right.
And the second is that that number is
acceptable.
I see what you're trading in there is
what are you getting?
So if you have an equation where they
can have these guns.
So what are you benefiting and what are
you losing?
Tell me what is the society we benefit
from handguns and rifles?
Well,
the people that have been able to
protect themselves against dangerous
crime,
the people that have been able to stop
people from breaking into their home,
stealing their property,
harming them physically or protecting
their level.
So when you talk about ratios,
there's 30,000 hand gun crimes in
America every year,
right?
That's it.
The document it have shootings.
30,000.
So I thought it was way more than that.
So if we take the percentage of people
that defended themselves,
I mean you've got five to 10 cases a
year like that doesn't actually occur,
but what are they defending themselves
against
those people with handguns and rifles.
So you're in,
you're trapped in this circular logic
where you need a gun because I have a
gun and then eventually Jamie says,
well those fuckers have a gun.
I want to gun two.
And we know where that goes.
We literally know it keeps getting more
and more and more.
Now if we have this perpetual society
where everyone has everything and
everything's perfect,
but that's just not gonna happen,
we're going to have strife and a lot of
these guns are concentrated in a few
people's hands that have 200 guns.
You know,
dudes that have 50 guns.
I know dudes that 50 guts.
I know due to so many guns.
Justin,
I'm talking about you motherfucker.
My Buddy Justin has so many guns.
He doesn't know know how many guns do
you have?
So they have those instances of giant.
He's seven feet tall and he has 150,000
fucking guns.
So they have,
they have them in a safe or they have
them out in rural America where they're
not even like interacting with people
like to have the strife.
Well,
he's a firearms enthusiastic and he is
also a guy with a squeaky clean criminal
record.
What's the argument against him being
able to be a firearms enthusiast and
possess all these guns because of what
it's done to our society.
He just wants to have something.
And I've talked to in particular,
I know,
but I'm just saying it because he's my
friend.
So anybody,
anybody.
What are you gaining?
So there's an equation in one,
one side of the equation,
we have 30,000 hand gun victims,
we have a society that's gripped by
fear.
We have dudes that can go get an ar 15
and days later,
light up a nightclub and do a hate
crime.
We know that that's gonna happen.
And we know that as the future
progresses,
that that 103 casualties of this
shooting is going to be superseded by a
bigger shooting that that's going to
happen because you know,
we got to break the records right?
And so,
and we're going to have more and more
guns that keep coming in and keep
coming.
So that's when the right hand side of
the equation and on your left hand side
of the equation for,
for having guns,
the argument is,
well I like them.
Well,
there's also the argument that a well
armed society is a polite society and
that there were people that had guns in
that nightclub.
They would've been able to prevent that
crime by taking that guy out.
There were eight cops.
I mean that was the same thing in
Denver.
Like if there were cops there,
but the cops are getting shot by the
cops get to a point where I wasn't
there.
A hostage situation.
I mean I don't know the details about
Florida.
So it's a,
it's really problematic.
We're true.
Cops wouldn't get killed,
right?
They have the biggest army.
That's when our streets.
So if more guns we keep having more cops
with more and bigger guns then it would
stop.
Right?
Because the cops,
the cops roll in armored vehicles with
ar fifteens to combat juveniles dominant
mall during the uprising.
So don't more cops shoot more criminals
than criminal shoot cops don't more cops
kill more people that are trying to
commit crimes than those people.
Of course,
that is predicated upon the premise that
they're trying to shoot the cops and
they're absolutely not.
We're trying to get away some of them.
Sure.
The ones that are actively trying to
shoot cops are super smart because you
got to read.
You're saying the cops are getting shot
when they do get shot.
Right?
Right,
right.
But what I'm saying is yes,
but isn't that sort of an argument that.
No,
no,
you bet.
And there is one guy with a rifle that
he purchased legally and a bunch of cops
and a bunch of cops.
The cops still get shot.
Right.
But a lot of those jobs.
But a lot of those guys that you're
talking about,
this one guys like the remember the
north Hollywood shootout famous of
course arm to the fucking gills and
wearing body armor and all that shit.
They were.
The cops were just so outgunned as far
as fire power.
Sure.
So our answers that they get more
firepower right now.
That's not saying that's the answer to
keep having.
This is one of the reasons why these
cops are getting shot.
They're getting shot and killed in that
situation in particular because they're
walking around with 38 revolver,
nine millimeter glock getting shot
because that guy has armor and a fucking
air through and saying,
this is what I'm saying is they don't
adequately.
Armed with a handgun would be perfectly
fucking fine if we didn't have ar 15
saturating our streets.
Will that guy.
I don't even think he had an ar 15.
You had something like that.
It's all heavy shit.
That's all.
Okay.
Yeah,
so like which by the way,
it's the same gun as an m 16 folks.
It's A.
It's a military weapon.
It's the same gun that was created.
It was created in the fifties to deal
with the AK 47.
There was an HPO,
a part series on real sports recently
that talked about it.
They were talking about Ar 15 in two to
three can do that damage.
That's a semiauto and we get caught up
in the assault weapons and the assault
weapons are going to keep you having
better aim.
They're going to keep you having a
higher magazine capacity.
Could be a little more reliable weapon,
but have a hunting rifle with a 10
magazine clips.
That's a two to three and it's a
semiautomatic is gonna do the exact same
level of damage that we're talking
about.
So my position on gun control is
extremely simple.
You want your guns for these other
things like say hunting bolt,
action rifles and shotguns.
There you go.
Everything that you can that's on your,
on the pro gun side that they want to
achieve can all be accomplished by
shotguns and bolt action rifles.
Well,
yeah,
I see that argument,
but I also see the argument that hunters
would use in that situation that if you
limit the amount of rounds that a guy
can have in his gun or the ability to
fire off round quickly,
you're limiting their ability to make a
quick followup shot on an animal that
would kill that animal.
Yeah.
And so if you have somebody that's that
dedicated,
right,
I don't have a problem with that
personally.
So if you have somebody that we want to
establish this high standard,
so say say we have the super high
standard where this guy,
he can get his big gun that he uses in
his well trained on and he's gone
through a super long process of
backgrounds and he's all checked out
that I don't have any objection to that.
But like say his gun gets stolen,
you don't get it anymore,
you're done.
Right.
So you have to maintain this high
standard in order to have such extreme
privilege.
And I'm fine with that.
Like people that have c,
four explosives,
you know,
there are people that can legally carry
det cord and c four to blow up
buildings.
They're not a big problem to the rest of
the society using their debt court and
see for,
to,
to hurt people.
So if that's a unique class of
individual.
Yeah,
I see what you're saying.
So you think that should be more
stringent testing and background checks
on people that are getting guns?
Yeah.
Especially those kind of high powered
ones or handguns,
we,
we get caught up a lot in the high power
because they're,
they're capable of that mass
destruction,
but it's the handguns that caused the
fear in society every single day because
it's so easy to conceal.
Yeah,
that's the whole problem is the
concealment that you can just pop it out
and use it.
You don't know who has what and so
everyone becomes a.
because you have
this small death device on you that
anybody can do anything and it's just
like we gotta go back to that equation,
like what is on the other side of the
equation of 30,000 handguns and $300
plus a mass shootings per year.
The other side of that equation is,
is that ridiculous idea.
I mean,
if you can figure out something for me
other than I liked collecting guns and I
think they're cool and it's my right
then,
then I'm willing to hear it.
I just don't hear an argument beyond
that.
Well,
the only argument is that a person who
is not a criminal and a person who
doesn't have any ill will in their
hearts and just enjoys firearm,
should be able to have them just like
you should be able to have a truck that
you could just drive through a fucking
crowd of people with if you want it to
yet,
but so the argument there that you can
have the truck and the truck is capable
of of harm,
so just like a knife,
but a knife has a drilling and other
uses.
So on that other side of that equation,
when you can say,
well,
what do we need a knife for?
Well,
it's to chop up food.
It's to skin a deer.
It's to do a thousand other things that
the ar or something like that.
It's for one purpose and one purpose
only and that's to kill a human being.
Well,
that was what it was designed for,
but people use them for hunting.
They have a better rifle to used in that
for hunting.
Well,
the thing about hunting with those is
that you can pull the trigger many times
like for hog hunting and things like
that.
There are a lot of people actually
prefer them.
Sure.
So let's say you even want to do that
again,
we're talking about that higher class
person and so higher-class hog hunter.
Yeah,
higher class.
I'm pretty sure that's not an actual
effect.
I'm like,
so you want to go shoot it and you want
to shoot those,
those animals,
right?
Go check it out from your parks and rec
and go use it.
Check out.
Yeah,
check it out.
You said you just want to use it right?
But what do you mean?
But check it out.
Right?
So say you could start at an armory
armory that who runs the government to
run.
Of course.
Good Lord.
It could be the private,
the private rifle range.
Okay.
Alright.
Well that's how it is in a lot of places
in Europe when you know how to do this
shit.
We literally,
other countries have done this.
Australia is the shining example.
They had one mass shooting said,
fuck this,
and I have none sense.
Right,
but you can get a rifle in Australia.
Okay,
and this is something that gets bandied
about many times,
so I actually had to do some research.
It's not impossible to get rifles for
hunting in Australia.
You could super hard.
It's difficult,
but Australia also has less people than
California and an enormous chunk of land
yet.
But we have other countries take China.
China's four times.
Our population doesn't.
It doesn't even hit the radar screen
when the amount of people they have
imprisoned or the amount of violence
they have.
That's true.
But China is.
Well was until really recently,
it's a communist dictatorship that was
run with an iron fist.
I mean,
think about Tiananmen and what happens
when people rebel against the government
there.
It's two completely different sort of
culture.
Is it?
Is it different than what happens here
though?
Really though,
I mean if you stand up against the
government was going to happen to you.
It's not just standing up against the
government.
I mean they,
the people,
they don't have much power over there
too.
We live in an oligarchy,
like we've proven that.
That's another thing we've proven,
so princeton did a study where they
tracked 19,000 cases of laws that were
going on and going through congress,
so what they found out is that public
opinion on whether a law gets passed or
not.
For instance,
gun control,
which over 80 percent of NRA members
agree with increased gun control and
background checks and things like that.
We don't get it passed congress at all.
It doesn't have any bearing on public
opinion,
doesn't have any bearing on whether a
law gets passed,
but if you have donors that care about a
law getting passed,
then it's going to get past.
And even when public sentiment is
completely against the law being passed.
If the public,
if the donors want the law passed,
they still have a 30 percent chance of
getting the law passed.
I think what the NRA is trying to do is
they're trying to prevent the slippery
slope.
They're trying to establish laws and
keep them in place so that established
rights that are already in place,
right?
Keep them in place because they worry
that if you start increasing background
checks,
if you start ramping up any sort of
restrictions on gun owners,
that it's a slippery slope that will.
They'll never get back.
They'll never get the freedom back.
But what I mean,
I don't know what that freedom is.
We're all afraid to go somewhere.
We don't have freedom in this gun
saturated country where we're not.
We'll hold on.
No,
we're not.
We're not.
I don't think people are afraid.
No,
I don't.
I don't think people are generally
afraid of fighting to keep the gun,
but hold on.
You're saying we're all afraid as if
every day when you go to the movies,
you're worried about a mass shooting
every day when you go to the wall and
we're not afraid.
We travel freely.
Occasionally things like this happen and
they're horrific and terrifying,
but people aren't generally afraid.
We're all afraid to do things.
I just don't think that's true.
I Dunno.
So
why then would we all want to protect
this so much?
Well,
the NRAS position,
the NRAS position is that Liberals,
Democrats,
whatever they want to take away your
right to own a gun,
the NRA does not want that.
So they spend all their money,
they do other lobbying,
they do everything they can to stop any
new restrictions from passing and to
stop anyone who is trying to take away
guns.
Right?
So,
so the way you framed that is that they
are trying to protect their rights and
they want to preserve this thing,
but I just don't see it that way.
A lot of people with those people that
are fighting against guns like so.
So me,
I have guns.
I like shooting,
I enjoy it.
I'm fucking good at it.
I made a career out of it,
right?
But
at one point in time I did enough
research and enough understanding that
my ultimate goal is that we have a safer
society and that we protect people.
But the way we protect people
empirically is to not have these guns.
Nobody has the gun crime that we have.
Nobody in the entire world as a
developed country has the gun crime and
incarceration rate in everything that we
do.
We are the worst example in the in the
developed world of how to do this.
Every other example is a better example
than what we do,
but we're continually trying to stay
into into this same mold that we know is
failing.
I want to protect people and the
evidence says that in order to protect
people,
we can't have handguns and assault
rifles there.
I said the damn assault right forward
again,
but we can't have a semiautomatic rifles
out there like crazy that enables
society to have that risk.
I mean those,
those on the other end of that stray
bullet is a nine year old girl who's
bleeding out to death in the city and I
just.
I don't want to get rude with people,
but the idea that you want to go fucking
shoot something,
I just don't give a shit about that.
When you see the destruction close to
you is suddenly Gabby Gifford can go
for,
for gun control after it touches,
you know,
or somebody like that.
Whenever it touches you,
suddenly we start to care if,
if right now a masked gunman comes and
starts shooting up the rest of this
building and they,
they killed Jamie,
we're all going to care a hell of a lot
more by Jamie.
How come you don't?
Because I didn't want to die that
Jamie under the bus please nobody.
Shoot Jamie.
And I think,
I think we would all take a slightly
different perspective.
I think you're right.
And I think that's an issue with all
sorts of crimes.
And uh,
that's also an issue with poverty and
bad communities is that it's not
touching.
The people that are,
that are just want to be safe.
Lock those people up,
get them off the street.
They're in my way.
I think you're right in that regard.
I mean,
I don't know if there is a perfect
answer to getting rid of 300 million
guns are controlled.
Don't think you can do it in guns.
I just want stop making them.
Yeah.
Like let's just stop making them.
So one of my ideas,
they are gun companies.
They're making a doctor.
They're making,
making a weapon of death.
I don't care about what they want.
So we know guns can last hundreds of
years if you take care of them.
Right?
So if we stop making them,
their value will all go up and then
we're going to concentrate it.
And I know the Libertarians would be
like,
oh my God,
all the rich people are gonna.
Hold the guns.
I get it.
Whatever.
They're not going to use them.
We know that.
So let's make it more valuable so
they're not worth $200 on the street so
that,
uh,
you know,
a gun of disrespect before a drug war,
beef can lead to that shooting.
I want to have you sit down with someone
who's a gun proponent.
Good luck.
What do you mean?
Good Lord,
I've been here for a year.
Doing this day in and day out,
challenging everyone from Sam Harris
to whoever.
They're not going to.
They're not going to do this.
The evidence is on my side.
They're not going to do what?
You're not going to have a debate
because it certainly would.
I could definitely set that,
set it up.
Okay,
well I can up my friend Justin.
100 percent you can get to do this
please because he needs to give me that
push back that other people need to hear
and if he's right on a position I will
absolutely change.
Okay,
well we're definitely going to set that
up then I'm going to bring in Justin
because Justin is very articulate and
don't be intimidated because he has a
giant,
does have a thousand fucking guns or
something like that.
But he's a nice guy.
He's a very nice guy.
He's a good buddy.
Um,
and he is a,
like I said,
and firearms enthusiast,
but also a really nice guy that has no
criminal record,
never done anything wrong and very
articulate.
Very smart,
very well read.
But he's going to say that people like
him should have the guns.
Right.
And he's,
he's right where he is,
right?
Yeah.
I mean he's never done anything with
those guys and he's the wrong fucking
dude to break into his house every once
in a while you're going to need a dude
like him to kick down the door,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
We know that,
so I wouldn't argue if he's going to say
he needs,
you know,
we need this elite members of society
that Swat teams or something like that
that can handle these situations.
Of course we do.
Well he's a competitive shooter.
Does contest and stuff.
They should shoot like me.
Well,
I'm sure he's right.
Like if they can handle it and their
professionalism as him,
you're not going to get pushed back from
society because nothing's going to
happen.
But it's what I'm saying is that he's
not doing anything wrong and it's
something he enjoys.
Like when do we decide,
and I'm just putting this out there.
I'm not taking a stance because I don't
understand it myself.
Uh,
and you know,
people saying that I'm anti-gun or pro
gun or not.
I'm pretty neutral on this.
I also owned guns,
but I see the problems.
I definitely see when something like
this happens in Orlando and some crazy
fuck can go in and just shoot up a
nightclub and kill all these people.
We've got a real problem.
I don't know how to solve that problem.
I'm sure some people would say concealed
carry permits,
so all these people in the nightclubs
could shoot out that guy,
but that's false.
It's empirically false gunfight in a
nightclub and more people are going to
get shot.
Well not only that,
most of the people that get involved in
these gunfights it will be their first
gunfight,
so you're going to fuck it.
Shit your pants.
You're going to get target panic.
You're going to miss,
you're going to hit people.
It's going to be a lot going on.
Glad you're saying that.
Yeah.
I mean it's not as simple as via to gun.
If he had a gun,
you'd probably wouldn't be able to point
it at people and if you pulled the
trigger,
you'd be lucky if you hit someone right
in front of you.
So where.
Where was that shooting?
It was relatively recent.
It was out of college and there were two
Marines on base on the college campus
with weapons and they didn't engage
because they said,
hey look,
I was only going to make the situation
worse.
The cops weren't going to know who I am
if I had my weapon out,
but I could have missed and done
something else.
And two guys that were in their actual
right state of mind that we're armed
decided that engaging was more dangerous
and it's actually empirically more that
if you engage,
your more likely to die and you're
something,
you're going to shoot somebody else or
the situation's not going to be
resolved.
We,
we,
we literally know this.
People have done this.
They've done studies where they've tried
to take people and simulate it and it
never pans out.
Yeah.
But that's engaging with,
uh,
an instance where you're not involved.
If you are involved,
you absolutely have to engage.
You're going to get shot.
Like if you're,
if
you have to run like so.
All the evidence says that if you run,
that's your best bet for safety.
And like,
we don't want to do that,
right?
Because that's a bitch move.
Please.
I'm done.
Someone shooting,
I'm all better hero.
There's this delusion of Hiroshima.
You know that somebody is going to save
the day.
And sure,
you may find that happen every so often.
It's,
wait a minute,
have you not seen Sylvester stallone
movies?
Because it happens all the time.
Is that that is a problem,
right?
Super problem that they shoot people in
the leg while they're running and Tulsa.
Like we've developed this sort of idea
of what goes down in a gunfight based on
fiction not based on reality.
The amount of people that have actually
been exposed to a bullet hitting a live
thing is so small sound.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
They don't realize how loud that is.
If you show shoot with,
with headphones in your whole life,
go ahead and start clacking off 15
rounds with without ear protection on
your.
You'll be ringing.
You can't even understand what's going
on.
You have to be well trained in that
environment and understand like cops
aren't even in there the first time they
get a real gun battle because they shoot
with earfold earplugs in and everything.
The first time they're shooting their
gun,
they're hearing the sound and everything
else.
So yeah,
I mean you got those people like
everybody that I was in the Marine Corps
with doing fast team,
I don't think they're going to get any
gun crimes and I think they can handle
situations,
but these are a certain segment that
needs to live up to a high standard.
Well not only that,
those are people that have been trained
and they've.
They've developed this understanding of
firearms that's so deep.
Most people just don't get to that.
It's like the average person watches a
UFC fight and thinks they can kick
someone's ass and then if you fought
against a train martial artists,
you're fucked.
Like you really don't know what you're
doing.
That's kind of the same thing.
And when you compare someone who really,
like my friend Justin really understands
firearms versus the average person who
goes and buys a gun and thinks,
well,
I'm safe now.
I got this gun.
It maybe,
maybe,
but statistics say that you're more
likely to shoot a family member and an
in a fight or yeah,
suicide.
Which,
you know the other thing,
a lot of people.
That's a wonderful analogy.
I love that you did that because I mean
it's a perfect analogy almost for mma
and who can handle a weapon as well,
but what's all about undue confidence,
you know,
and perfect.
So like here's,
here's the thing,
I've always wanted to tell people that
feel that way.
We can.
I can tell you,
you can have a gun on you right now and
we can set this up in the morning and I
can tell you,
walk around your day as normal at some
point in time today,
I'm going to take that gun away from
you,
right?
I will get that gun.
It's going to happen because you,
you're not going to be able to protect
it and you know I'm coming.
So then why are you actually think
you're safe,
that you have that gun on you.
You're just,
as long as you're fighting against the
inferior opponent or you're in this
situation where you have distance and
you have all these things like that,
just like in an MMA fight,
it's not going to go as you planned it,
I promise.
So what are you saying?
Look,
as far as like you're going to take the
gun away from him.
Let's say you wanted to have a concealed
weapon on you.
Right?
And so you're standing in line at the
bank.
You're going about your day as normal.
I could tell you at some point in time
I'm going to get that gun from you and
I'll get it because if everything's
about surprise.
So when the bank robber comes in,
well it's not surprised if you tell them
you're going to get it.
Well sure.
I've just given you 24 hours,
I'll be all fucking jacked up on
adderall for 24 hours.
Thinking about the life you're meant to
keep that gun safe,
you definitely wouldn't be.
Well it makes it an adventure.
Wait,
but that's the thing that you're bigger
than me.
You can be ready for it.
It's still.
I'm sorry.
You're just not going to be because it's
just going to come out of nowhere.
So when people have these guns,
are you like really good at disarming
people or something?
No,
more than anybody else would be.
If you learn how to a holster works.
Somebody goes from my gun,
I'm punching him in their fucking face.
Come from behind you.
We're going to be standing in line at a
w.
where's my gun?
When your head right here.
So they're going to come from behind.
They're going to grab it.
Sure you can do.
But how hard is it to get a gun out of a
holster?
There's certain holsters,
as long as you know the holster works.
It's cake.
Oh,
okay.
What does that one holster wear?
If you yank on it?
It doesn't work with the triple
retention holsters.
Yeah.
I'm really going to see your gun if you
have one of those because those are
pretty darn big.
What if I'm wearing a puffy coat?
Sure.
I guess you could figure out ways to get
around it.
I'm good at that,
but you're just not actually safer.
I know a dude who keeps several guns on
them all the time and two knives.
He's got a knife in his boot.
He keeps several guns on them all the
time.
He's been hitting the head a bunch of
times,
so it's just.
Some people think you just,
you can't.
You can't think that that's what's going
to make you safe.
It's your mindset,
it's your,
it's your awareness of your
surroundings.
It's your ability to make logical
decisions.
Okay.
But you're talking about a very specific
case where someone's trying to take your
gun away.
Right?
But that's the thing is you're in a,
you're in a bank.
I don't even need a gun because odds are
they're going to be one there
and that's what we have.
So like a big thing of policing is you
don't get into like Jujitsu Kinda of
wrestling matches because of that gun.
Right?
Because no matter what fight you're in,
there's always a gun there.
And it's the same thing with non cops,
right?
You don't want to get in a fight as a
cop because if the evidence shows
statistically that if they get that gun
from you,
they're going to use it on you.
Right?
That's no different from you.
If they get that gun from you can use it
on you.
Right?
Right.
So why would you want to be in a fight
with somebody?
Well,
that's a wrestling match,
right?
So you're saying that.
But I introduce the gun,
you're introducing that potential for
you dying and there's a high possibility
and you didn't have it before.
You literally are making yourself more
at risk.
I mean the statistics are clear on this
that if you bring a gun to this fight,
the odds are against you even higher now
because most people that bring a,
if even if you bring a knife to a fight
at a significant portion of those people
get the knife taken away from them.
It gets used on them.
I can't tell you how many cases we've
been where you're trying to figure out a
stabbing call and come to find out.
Know they tried to do the stabbing,
but they got that shit taken from them
and they got stabbed themselves.
So once you introduce that,
that potential,
you were more dangerous or yourself.
But this is again,
you're talking about non trained
individuals and it sort of brings us
back to you and I not the
responsibilities.
They fight hard on those really trained
people.
I get that.
Yeah,
no,
that,
that's fine.
And that's not a right at that point.
It's a privilege.
So it's like driving a car,
driving your car on a right,
it's a privilege.
So if these people want to earn that
privilege,
so be it.
But it becomes a problem,
doesn't it?
When a really fucking crazy person earns
that privilege.
I mean,
if someone hasn't done anything yet
criminal,
I mean there's been several people that
have committed mass shootings but didn't
do anything before they did that
shooting.
I mean,
yeah.
So,
so you're still left with those.
You still decided as a society that on
that side of the equation,
you're willing to accept that amount
even though it's a lesser amount,
you have decided to set that amount and
if we can just move to a point where we
can accept a lesser amount,
that would be wonderful.
But we're continually accepting in ever
increasing amounts because more people
are buying guns,
more people buying ammo.
Hm.
So what is the solution then in your
eyes?
Well,
I would like to stop manufacturing.
I would,
uh,
like handguns and rifles to be banned.
And maybe that has to take a long time.
Not Rifle.
It's just a semiautomatic,
meaning you can't own them anymore.
No,
let's not go.
Shit.
Yeah,
same trick is shit.
Then it becomes a privilege.
So like the handguns,
your twitter accounts getting attacked
right now and that was a real fucking
liberal.
You're never taking my gun.
So you have to be those people that
earned that privilege.
The idea that it's a right.
It's just,
I think,
I think we could call it a lot in that,
that it's just even if it,
like we were saying earlier,
I think the evidence is there that it's
actually not.
You're right,
but if it is like,
can we rethink that?
I mean,
what is the Second Amendment?
Read it exactly.
Jamie.
In its form please.
So we can be again,
the idea that we keep the constitution
and the bill of rights exactly intact
some shit that was created hundreds of
years ago before any of the variables
that we have to deal with in society,
whether
it's variables about privacy,
electronic communications,
whether it's variables about the power
and the ability that guns have.
I mean we're dealing with a totally
different world.
They made the shit back when people had
muskets,
we really need to consider that and by
the way,
they had just gotten done fighting off a
totalitarian regime and had expanded and
become their own country.
Second,
I'm in the United States.
Constitution reads a well regulated
militia being necessary to the security
of a free state.
The right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed.
See,
that's pretty clear.
The right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed.
Yeah,
but a well regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
state,
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed if they are
a well regulated militia,
but it's not saying if it's saying
capital letter a,
a well regulated militia being necessary
to the security of the free state,
so they're establishing that it is
important that you have a well regulated
militia being necessary.
Well-Regulated.
That's the weird term.
Well regulated militia.
What does that mean?
National Guard?
Is that what they're saying though?
Because it's saying the right of the
people to keep and bear arms right?
They will not be in the state though.
So the idea that you fight,
what is it?
People of the state mean they're just
people know because that's what the
states are mean.
We the people that's the country,
right?
But this is a free,
a free state.
What that means is they,
they're worried that we might be invaded
and taken over by England at the
government or the government.
Any government.
It's against the federal government.
Right.
So that's a state being able to defend
itself against the federal government
because they still were lingering with
that.
That from Britain.
I don't know if that's what they meant
when they said a free state.
Is that what they could pull that up
again so I can see that please.
It's,
I mean,
look,
it's kind of weird arguing about this
because if we had to do this over again,
I mean this is obviously something that
was established as we said a long time
ago.
If we had to do this over again,
if we had established new new amendments
or new rights,
I don't know how we would rate,
but that's a prep propositional phrase,
a well regulated militia.
That means everything after that is in
regards to a well reg and Mr. so if I
said and then Joe and everything in that
sentence would be about.
Joe is a prepositional phrase.
I mean that that's exactly what they
mean.
Well,
a rel.
Well regulated militia,
meaning that there's a bunch of militia
meaning regular people,
civilians gathering together to form
some sort of a makeshift army.
Yeah.
Being necessary to the security of a
free state.
Now when they say a free state,
this is back when,
what were their fucking three states or
something like that.
When the 13 isn't,
should've been 13.
Then the first ones were 13,
right.
The first initial states,
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed.
Sees fucking.
Nobody talks like that.
You fucks,
you know today in 2016 if you wrote a
sentence like that,
but like,
hey bitch,
what are you trying to say?
You know what I mean?
I mean,
people,
thou shalt not for score in 16 years ago
what?
Speak Normal Bitch,
right?
It's,
um,
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed is the one
that everybody claims to.
People of the Free State though,
is that,
that's definitely what they meant
because they did that back then.
You know,
they,
they formulated those,
those books,
but they're saying shall not be
infringed the right of the people.
But remember,
that's the federal government shall not
infringe that right against the state.
No,
it's not saying against the state.
It's saying the people to put attack the
security of the state,
the right of the people to keep in bare
arms shall not be infringed the people
of this state.
Right?
But what they're saying is that was
annoying for people listening.
We got to do the car chase story after
this,
that we all.
Everybody.
Oh,
that's right,
that's right.
A well regulated militia being
necessary.
So there's establishing that.
And again,
if you're angry right now and you'll
fuck I'm writing my congressman,
you fucking pussies and try to take my
guns.
We're just trying to.
We're trying to unpack this amendment,
a well regulated militia being necessary
to the security of a free state.
So they're establishing that we need a
well regulated militia to make sure that
we don't get taken over by tyranny.
The right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed.
I don't know man.
I mean I'm not a constitutionalist by
any stretch of the imagination.
Nor am I a scholar of the bill of
rights.
That seems pretty clear.
The right shall not be infringed.
Okay.
So I'll give you.
Let's say we give you the right of the
people is what they mean is that the
people can hold the arms until they're
needed to form this militia.
Well that's weird because that is what
it sounds like to me to hold the arms.
Yeah.
So the people,
right of the people to keep and bear
arms.
Right?
So they have the guns,
right?
And so they can have them.
It's just that so that they can
formulate a well regulated militia later
if needed,
so it does kind of relate that as well.
I don't know about,
but you don't think so.
No.
The right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be in front of the people
have the guns.
Right?
What I'm saying.
And then the idea could be that they
meant that you can have the guns in case
you need to formulate the militia to
fight tyranny.
It could be read that way in case.
Yeah.
Well it's just not giving you any
options and saying shall not be
infringed.
Scroll down.
What is it saying?
What is the Second Amendment?
Actually said the exact same.
That was.
What is the definition of modern
definition of the rights granted by the
second amendment.
Is there any sort of legal.
Nobody's agreed on this thing.
Yeah.
It seems like these cocksuckers that
wrote that chair,
they've made it so weird,
but even if you can get them,
like they certainly weren't talking
about Ar fifteens and they weren't
envisioning a government with 5,000
nuclear weapons.
Right?
Then they weren't envisioning 300
million people.
The PROZAC,
the idea of fighting the government just
really seems weird like so what you're
saying there.
So I was in the Marine Corps.
What you're saying then is that if they
make a wall like trump gets into office
and he says,
all right,
that's it.
We're going to crack down on our people.
You think that I'm going to come after
you for that.
Come on,
come on.
Like the the most.
Some people will.
People at our military will not do that.
These generals aren't going to do that.
They're not going to command their their
members.
Do you have a military coup?
You probably would,
but you will have some people that are
willing to comply,
but you are saying that your friends and
brothers and sisters that are in the
armed forces are going to turn their
guns on their friends and family.
Get the fuck out.
That's interesting because you could
make that same argument about the
police.
You're saying that your friends and
brothers and sisters that are in the
police are going to turn their guns on
the civilians,
so they do.
They do,
but that's a small amount of people that
are affected.
So if you're talking about affecting the
entire country,
then those people will have that
personal effect because it's not just
there,
they're turning on their own family.
They're not just turning the same
argument that a small amount of
noncompliant people would be the ones
that the military would have to go
against.
Yeah,
I mean,
I guess if you have that kind of
scenario,
sure.
It's Kinda the same.
They're literally say they were to come
take all the guns and they were going to
do it by force.
Right.
You're also seeing this huge force for
one,
the military is not allowed to operate
on our soil,
but they already do.
They're already rolling the national
guard through cities.
And if you look at,
well have a well regulated militia.
Yeah.
Look,
I mean when you look at the tanks and
some of the,
uh,
the,
the fucking military vehicles that
they're using in some of these riot
drill militarization of police is a
separate,
a separate argument.
Well,
it is a separate argument,
but it becomes a military then.
I mean,
you're talking about war machines,
that's something that clearly wasn't
envisioned and so I would rather you
didn't open up that.
It's another channel.
Arms Man.
Fuck,
where's this going?
Right?
Yeah,
this is it.
It's a very unusual sort of a debate
because I see both sides.
I absolutely see both sides.
Just remember that equation though.
The both sides of that equation where
they can be logical.
One side of that equation is death.
Well,
and the other argument would be that
protecting yourself against death is a
right,
but we know that if you want to have a
safer society,
if you want to live in Australia,
you have to get rid of the Goddamn guns.
Yeah,
but Australia so different than adults.
I just don't buy those small.
I don't buy that.
We buy it this way by it this way.
How many mass shootings have there ever
been in California besides San
Bernardino?
Take San Bernardino out of the mix.
How many black people in the hood that
we don't hear about?
Hm,
okay.
Mass shootings in this country daily,
so you're going to get them every week
or two weeks in California.
Do they really get them every week or
two weeks in California?
Yeah.
You just don't hear about them because
you're tall because they happen in
Compton.
No one gives a shit.
Right,
and you're.
You're talking about people who are
criminals shooting other criminals and
that's one of the arguments that gun
control,
anti gun control people use against
people that talk about how many people
get shot.
It's how many people.
Like when you look at the numbers of
people that get shot in this country,
there are also calculating the number of
people that are shot by law enforcement
officers.
Oh sure.
They do know they don't even get counted
as they don't get reported to the FBI.
The Guardian just figured out how many
people got shot.
The Twenty 15 is the first year we
figured out how many people got shot by
police in this country.
Okay,
but it is 2016 and we do calculate,
you know,
the newspaper does it,
the federal government or nobody doesn't
look up statistics of how many people
are killed by guns every year.
They do include bad guys killed by cops.
Know what?
No.
So an argument that Ted nugent is don't
count as homicides either.
Well,
we're not talking about homicides were
just talking about the them.
It doesn't count.
No,
it doesn't count against our homicide
count because it's considered justified,
justified.
Homicides don't count,
but deaths,
they don't.
I don't think they use the word homicide
when they're counting firearm deaths.
Interesting point.
Let's follow that up because this was
what a Ted nugent and Piers Morgan,
I can't believe I'm using Ted nugent.
One appears.
Well,
he's piece of shit,
but he what his argument with Ted
Nugent,
he got shredded and then argument
because he,
he went into it on armed with facts and
nugent spews this out every point he
can,
and by the way,
he would argue with you all day.
Sure.
But that's,
that's arguing with crazy person.
He's allegedly was crazy.
A little crazy.
That's not go.
There are certain people I'm willing to
call out from time to time.
That'd be one of them.
You think Ted knew just crazy is crazy
bottom.
Have you seen him talk clearly crazy.
He's going to argue that until the end
of day you can.
He's one of those people.
You can put the evidence in front of him
day in and day out and he'll just move
the goal and moved the goalpost and no
one's interested in having an argument
with somebody who's just going to
continually move posts.
I don't know about all that.
I don't know if he would move the
goalposts.
Say the one thing that he makes coherent
arguments about is in fact against gun
control.
What do we got there at Jamie?
I'm halfway
something,
but I got this,
uh,
from the Washington Post,
this article that starts with the year
of 1000 people nearly being shot by
police.
That sound as annoying.
But,
um,
it says right here they start to compile
a record of every fatal police shooting
in the nation as of 20 15 something no
government agency had done.
It started after Michael Brown shooting.
That was when they started looking into
it.
British newspaper did that Goddamn
commies or whatever they are.
It's Washington Post,
but other posts
so sought to compile a record.
This is a Washington Post.
The Guardian started,
but it says the post sought to compile a
record of every fatal police shooting in
the nation.
Two thousand 15 something no government
agency had done the project,
began after police officers shot and
killed Michael Brown in Ferguson,
Missouri in August of 2014,
provoking several nights of fire rise,
blah,
blah.
Race remains the most volatile
flashpoint in any accounting of police
shooting.
The black men make up only six percent
of the US population.
They account for 40 percent of the
unarmed men shot to death by police this
year.
The Post database shows in the majority
of cases which police shot and killed a
person who had attacked someone with a
weapon or brandished a gun.
The person who was shot was white.
Hmm.
Interesting.
That's interesting.
Why hasn't the majority of cases in
which police shot and killed a person
who had attacked someone with a weapon
or brandished a gun?
The person was shot,
was white,
but a huge disproportionate number three
and five of those killed after
exhibiting less threatening behavior
were black or Hispanic,
so meaning they valued the life less of
people who are black or Hispanic.
They were quicker to shoot them with
less threatening behavior than they
would with white people regardless,
regardless of race and more than a
quarter of the cases,
the fatal encounter involved officers
pursuing someone on foot or by car
making chases one of the most common
scenarios in the data.
Hmm.
That's interesting.
That's interesting that it's shooting
more white people,
but I guess there are more white,
more white people.
It's because there's one percent of the
population.
It's probably more than that,
right?
How many of them?
White people either see.
It's getting down.
It's going down slowly.
Brown people are fucking their way up to
the top.
We joke about that.
How?
What does that movie where everything
goes crazy stupid?
Come on.
Which one?
Michael Douglas.
No purge.
No.
Idiocracy,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
So like the silly one,
we know,
we know that the more educated someone
is,
the less kids they have.
So as soon as you do that you go,
oh no,
fuck.
All the smart people don't have kids.
Right.
And everybody that's poor as poor kids.
So like that's why another reason why we
have to educate.
Yeah,
the counter to overpopulation that when
they look at the charts and graphs that
when you,
uh,
in industrialized nations,
when they become more closer to the
first world,
they have less children.
China.
Yeah.
But it's also,
they're also puck and working more
grinding son necessarily.
Good.
My might be better off being poor with a
bunch of kids and be happy.
All right.
So we know that the most likely time to
get to a shooting is in a chase.
Yeah.
So we owe chase story and we should
lighten this up a little bit.
Okay.
Let's.
So this is a story.
This is the story that we just got
sidetracked from
the first conversation.
We're in the middle of talking about it.
We never got to it.
So.
All right.
We were talking Jamie and I earlier
about it would probably be pretty cool.
We can probably pull this up on street
maps,
so let's go to the 1800 block of West
Pratt.
We can actually look at it.
Okay,
interesting.
Anybody who's got their finger on the
send button right now,
ready to send an evil email or twitter,
but just relax.
This is a debate folks.
This is a conversation.
I know you wish you were here.
She could yell at Mike or me.
I don't know.
You said a pretty a.
you've made a couple of points that I
didn't even think about that.
We're pretty darn liberal.
I'm pretty liberal.
I'm a fucking confusing motherfucker.
If you're trying to pigeonhole me.
I'm a.
I'm a liberal Hippie who owns guns and
hunts and loves weed and gay people.
I love.
I love everybody.
All right.
Can we do.
Can we go to.
Okay,
so this is the uh,
so go down to that red awning and turn
around.
First of all,
how dope is Google maps?
It's crazy where we're traveling through
Baltimore right now on Jamie's
computers.
This is madness.
When we see in people's license plates
and shit,
that's so weird that they can do that.
They could just zoom in if caught people
coming out of whorehouse yeah,
they have.
People have sued because the Google
cars.
Yeah,
the Google car drove by right when
they're just lighting up a cigarette.
All right.
Face.
They'll left Jamie.
Okay.
So this is a really dilapidated
neighborhood in Baltimore.
We don't need to necessarily see it,
but we're dealing with dea.
A space h o o d.
okay.
I'm sorry.
Go left it.
Go down the street a little bit more
by the way,
since we're talking about Baltimore.
Shout out to my brother John.
Rollo.
Baltimore.
Alright.
So this is one of my ground control mma.
Go there.
Learn how to fight.
Right?
So I'm going to tell the story if I
could get my bearings right because it
doesn't seem like I'm going to be able
to pull it off.
It's okay.
Alright.
So anyway,
I'll just tell the story.
So one of my favorite times ever,
best night ever had as a cop,
we were working in major case squad and
we had been assigned a new vr.
Oh,
which is a violent repeat offender
target to go after.
You're going to hear a lot of these in,
a lot of chiefs are starting to push
this out again,
which is the violent repeat offender
where they have people with um,
so they,
they do like this predictiveness that
these are the people that were likely to
get shot or likely to do shootings or
something like that.
So we want to focus all of our
enforcement efforts on them to get them
on anything.
It doesn't work.
But regardless,
that's what I was doing at the time.
And we had a guy set up to the bar and
at the bar and we knew that this gang go
in and out of this bar.
So we had a guy sit in,
covert in a van and watch the bar
because we,
our whole intent was to take pictures,
take pictures,
document who is going in and try and see
some associations.
And me and another car.
We were hiding away,
just waiting to see what he reported.
Maybe we could follow somebody,
things like that.
And we're talking and I spent hours.
We're on like our 10 sitting there,
nothing going on and we had a secure
channel so we could just talk back and
forth on our radio and they're talking
about sports or something.
Had to be soccer,
baseball because it was so nice to give
a shit about.
So everybody's bitching,
going back on the radio,
just talk and trying to pass the time.
And then the guy watching and covert,
he goes,
finally here and coming here.
He said,
God,
would you shut the fuck up?
Shut up.
They're robbing the store next to me
right now.
I'm watching them.
I could see that it's a silver 38 into
dude's hand robbing the store.
Shut the fuck up and get over here.
So we're like,
alright,
alright.
So he's calling it out and these guys
running,
they get into a getaway car and go
around the block and we get behind them.
So we're following them and they know
this is a fresh robbery and so they got
hand guns in the car and everything.
Do they know you're following?
Nope.
So we have our cars and we're following
behind him and we're in this area where
you have the one district to the left,
to the west,
the southwest.
You have the western district in north
and the southern till left.
So they called the Tri district but
we're kind of in this area where
communications are going to be weird
because these are all different
channels.
So I'm riding with the sergeant.
I was a detective at the time and say to
him,
uh,
I'm going to get on southern channel.
You get on a southwest and coordinate
that way.
We can call this out.
So I get on the radio and I'm calling.
I'm like,
I need a 10:31,
uh,
on the southern channel and everybody
keeps talking.
We're trying to follow him.
I need a 10:31 on the southern channel.
And I'm looking at him like,
why the fuck don't they shut up?
Like,
I don't understand.
It's like the 10,
33 fucking asshole,
like Oh,
okay.
So I'll get on radio 10:30 to 10,
31 is to this day three is an emergency.
So I get on there and we're,
we're calling it out the car going
westbound,
Lombard and where we're following it and
we're coming up to the shopping center.
Turns left on Thompson or the cars full
of people.
It gets to the,
goes through the shopping center and it
stops at a stop sign,
but there's a car in front of it and
we're thinking,
all right,
we're going to have to light it up here.
But that car,
like it always moves right soon as we
hit the lights.
You can,
you can bet that car is going to move.
So we had the lights anyway and the car
stops in the front row so they can't get
past right.
So they all bail out a one run.
So there's four people in the car.
One goes one way,
one goes back the other way,
one goes for,
one goes behind and I jump out of the
car because uh,
let's see.
Alright.
So I leave my radio by accident and I
drop it because,
let's be honest,
I,
I see a guy running with a gun out of a
car and I'm still like in Jack Rabbit
bowed,
you know I'm,
I'm going on.
That's when people shoot people,
right?
Right.
I'm getting him.
So I take off without the,
without my radio chasing.
This dude going behind the shopping
center.
The sergeant,
he forgot to put the car in park so he
knows I don't have my radio.
He starting to panic about where I'm
going.
He has to dive back into the car to put
it on park so it doesn't hit the
suspect's car.
And then the non suspect car in front of
them,
the everybody goes running.
I'm chasing behind him and I've got my
gun out and I'm running and I'm saying,
you know,
hey,
I'm going to fucking shoot Yo.
You better stop now.
But I could tell he eat when he's
running.
He's fucking pure panic.
Like I had a moment of empathy for him
like you could.
He was just like,
fuck fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Running with that gun in his hand.
I'm like,
Oh,
you better drop it,
but running some guy comes out of the
woods for behind the shopping center.
It's a fucking cop from the southwest
who heard us on the radio plainclothes
cop.
So the guy froze the gun and he tries to
throw it up onto the roof of the
building,
but it's pathetically just hits the
building and staff at,
uh,
the guy coming out of the woods.
I yelled at him to get him while I run
it back,
go back and get the gun.
You got to get the gun first.
Uh,
if you're smart because that could end
up with somebody else's hands or or
whatever.
And we'll get him back.
And so at that moment,
unbeknownst to me,
all those districts were like all
coordinators,
like this moment of serendipity and
policing,
southern district patrol came up and got
one of the guys and like Western patrol,
got one of the guys and southwest
commander was in the area,
was there and that drug unit was there
helping me.
And we caught every single person,
bring them back.
We got like four guns.
We get everything rolling them over
fucking people we were looking for by
mere coincidence,
half a gag that we were looking for to
go into the Bar,
robbed the store that was next to our
guy in covert and we started our case
there which ended up being completely
successful because we had this huge
jumpstart of just dumb ass luck.
That does sound like dumb ass luck
because called 10:31 AM,
10:33,
forgot to put the car in park.
You left your radio behind that.
And that's typical,
you know,
so that's the way it is and that's a
situation where you do shoot like people
shoot in that situation,
but I think people think,
I haven't been there.
Who you haven't been,
you know who they are.
They're all over the internet,
the twitter trolls and stuff or people
who want to get credit to other cops,
you know,
they think,
oh,
you're just talking about Baltimore.
You've never actually done anything.
What did you actually do?
And those are the situations where you
get into these shootings,
right?
Where you could have easily shot that
guy who was running with a gun and
that's what the statistics show happens.
A lot of the time that would have
dramatically affected me,
dramatically affected him and everyone
around.
But what this kid was doing in the end
was being part of a drug deal,
trying to do robberies,
trying to fucking eat and survive and
yet we had those guns.
So you have this poverty and you have
this fighting for resources and so they
chose that to rob the store and to being
in these gangs.
But if they didn't have those guns,
how differently would that have been?
Probably quite a bit.
Yeah.
So.
So when you talk about saturation
mainly,
look in that incident we got lucky.
Everything went fine and it had
potential to ballpark.
Luckily we were all competent in that
unit,
but sorta thanks.
I was the youngest one was the rookie.
Cut Me some slack,
but you had 30 guns going around in that
situation and it's just like,
oh,
you just don't.
Like England doesn't do this.
You don't see other countries like this
where this all could have just went
bonkers because we're trying to respond
to a situation in a way go after people
and put them in cells because we have
this,
these guns everywhere,
and they're fighting for these
resources,
but that's where we have to stop and
say,
well,
why are they here?
What got us to this point?
Instead,
what we continue to do is we just throw
that group into jail and the very next
time it took us like six months to take
the whole group down.
We've got everybody federally indicted,
but as soon as we do that,
the next group just steps up because we
didn't take a moment to look at the
causation.
Well,
you know,
the old argument,
if you outlaw guns,
only outlaws will have guns.
Right?
Well,
I mean,
that's circular logic to it is,
but when you're dealing with a supply
that already exists in the hundreds of
millions,
it's pretty logical actually.
Yeah.
I mean,
it's gonna happen,
but you have to go door to door and dig
into people's basements.
But if you make guns illegal,
then uh,
then the only people that have guns are
law abiding people.
What do you mean?
No?
And completely legal.
Completely legal.
So that's why what you mean?
Yeah.
So that's why it's a circular logic.
So because those are.
The criminals are still criminals.
Even if the guns are illegal,
it's not everyone's on a law abiding
citizen that has a gun.
If you give a gun to a criminal,
right.
But if you don't have the law in place
to make it criminal.
And that's the thing we're saying,
well only bad guys will have guns if we
outlaw them.
All right,
well yeah,
because we outlawed them all.
I mean that's just,
it's circular logic.
So if we have the law first,
because you're not changing the gun
ownership,
you're just changing the law.
Right?
But you're already.
We've already made it illegal for people
that are felons to possess firearms.
Yeah.
But when you have that level of
saturation,
obviously it doesn't work.
Right?
But it gets back to the same issue.
Like how would you ever pass?
It's like trying to get,
you know,
it's like taking a bucket of water and
thrown it into the ocean and trying to
get that fresh water out.
Like how do you get out the guns that
are in the stop adding salt so we can't
instantly solve it.
We just have to stop doing it the wrong
way.
That's like the drug war.
I mean you,
you've been into the drug war so you
know,
without a doubt it doesn't work.
But what are we still doing?
And like it's,
I know we're slowly moving away from
that.
Sure.
I mean we should stop right now.
I mean like you can literally just
stopped it just as quickly as we started
it.
We can say okay,
we're not going to imprison people for
those offenses.
If they get into crime and they shoot
somebody,
well then go after them for the
shooting.
But what we do is we put that law in
there and we make it,
you know,
with like we're creating this,
we know what's wrong and we know to just
stop this.
So with the guns,
you know,
if he just stopped manufacturing them,
we'll get somewhere if you just stopped
locking people up for the drug war were
get somewhere and improving that.
But we're not.
We're just keep doing the scenes.
So it's been a year since I was here and
we discussed these drug war issues.
We haven't really moved the bar much
more.
The only thing that it is up for ballot
and several different states.
Marijuana,
of course not,
not other drugs and slowly but surely it
will become legal throughout the United
States.
Most likely now Washington DC is legal.
There's a lot of places that are illegal
now that weren't legal before and then
it's on the ballot in November in
California and several other states.
I believe that other states as well.
But ca marijuana is just one really
benign law.
I mean it's really,
it's,
it's a rather benign substance in many
ways.
It's not,
it's not a dangerous thing.
It's not a real threat or harm to
society.
Guns are way more dangerous.
Sure.
So moving that,
changing that.
But we're creating that,
you know,
so we create the guns are being used
because of the drug war.
Right.
And then we have people that are dying
of heroin overdoses because of the drug
war and notice we've had a lot of
improvements when people were dying of a
heroin overdose is now that it's in
Massachusetts and stuff.
What do you mean?
In Massachusetts?
Way are like the cops aren't arresting.
There's a,
there's a chief there that decided he
was going to be smart and he wasn't
going to lock up the heroin users.
He was going to get them into treatment.
[inaudible] has had excellent success
with the heroin problem.
That was a one on one of those cnn shows
was detailing what actually went,
went down.
Oh,
it was Anthony Bourdain show.
They were talking about how what,
what really happened was so many people
got addicted to Oxycontin is because of
prescription drug companies pushing that
shit where people,
you know,
when people are like little small,
minor injuries and they're prescribing
pills that are opiates and highly
addictive.
They're no different than heroin.
Yeah.
I mean like literally their heroin.
And so that's money in politics issue.
Again,
we're not fighting the,
those drug dealers who are getting
everybody hooked on heroin.
We're fighting the drug dealers that are
in the city still.
Yeah,
that's a gigantic issue of course.
Um,
and then these people,
when they started to crack down on
Oxycontin's,
that is when heroin moved in to take its
place because these people are sick.
They needed their pills,
they didn't get their pill.
So then they got heroin instead
rent.
Yeah.
I don't know,
but I mean,
so to move onto some reform measures are
what's being shown in the last year.
Yeah,
definitely.
Yeah.
Um,
alright.
So let's talk about what happened as the
years gone on.
Um,
after I left here,
uh,
obviously people picked up and I had
that,
you know,
the Joe Rogan effect that they,
everybody always talks about after they
talked to you,
other people started to pay attention.
And I went back to Baltimore,
um,
and his dude sends me an email and it
says they arrange it through leap that
he's going to come visit me and he wants
to talk about a movie.
Oh Jesus.
And so he calls so they corrupt you,
it would get you and we talk about some
of these ideas,
a very good movie idea that he as trying
to kind of put some of these things into
an emotional appeal that people can
understand and,
and comes close to them.
But what that did was,
is it,
it pushed me to get more involved in
Baltimore so I could get the other
people involved in the project that
would have good ideas and would really
know the streets well and with know the
activism path and what was going on with
black lives matter and everything in
there.
And so I reached out to a bunch of the
activists and we started forming these
tight knit groups and come to find out
this dude doing the movie is matthew
costs of Itch.
And I don't know if he's going to do it
yet or not,
but he's like this big star in France.
And thinking about doing a sequel to
moving me.
He may call Lehane,
which really talks about these kinds of
things in France.
France had very similar hyper
segregation problems and ghettoization
20 years ago.
And ended up having riots and they,
they did a lot to fix it and that's what
he's kind of doing like a 20 year
reunion of that.
But getting involved in Baltimore and
meeting everybody I really have been
like in a school,
I'm a of understanding of what the
cities need and what people are trying
to fight for,
what the black lives matter movement
really means.
Um,
I,
I just didn't,
I had all of those preconceived notions
of like,
you know,
being a white hero kind of thing where
you go and you help and like your
bringing your skills down and you don't
realize the things you're saying and how
you play into privilege and things like
that.
And getting them going in there with
them.
Uh,
my,
my walls against Muslims got got torn
down because I ended up meeting Muslim
activists who were really treat using
religion to do the right things,
you know,
the good things,
the selective of course,
but getting involved in the movement to
the point where we're having these,
these groups and we're doing things
like,
uh,
having panel discussions.
And we did like a stop and Frisk for
people so that they would see what it
was like to actually have somebody come
up on you and search through your
pockets.
And we've been doing documentaries,
uh,
we've been doing protesting where
there's a met this lady Twanda Jones,
who her brother was killed by Baltimore
police officers a couple of years ago
and she's been protesting every single
Wednesday for two and a half years
fighting for her brother,
tyrone west and I guess why they do it
on Wednesdays.
And He,
uh,
he was beaten to death by Baltimore
cops,
like literally beaten to death.
And we wanted to have things like where
we say,
why don't we have people protesting
good,
why is it always got to be like burning
down the cvs or something like that.
Whereas all the good people and like I
was just flabbergasted that they were
everywhere in,
in,
in what everyone thinks is the worst of
neighborhoods,
was just filled with people trying to do
the right thing and trying to fight for
justice and doing it in the most
peaceful manner.
Her brother was beaten to death by cops
and what she does is peacefully protest
every Wednesday for two and a half years
and doesn't get any attention for that
when they have other cops that were
those same cops beat this guy,
Abdul Salaam,
uh,
in front of his kid doing the exact same
kind of aggressive enforcement and it.
But it opens up a kind of winded way of
going about it is I got to see the other
side and that really has affected me.
That being a cop,
you lock them up and you put them into
the cell or are you taking the court and
the case goes or whatever.
You don't think about what that does on
the other end.
You never see.
And then I got involved in the
communities and I saw the other side.
I saw what it was like for a guy that
came back from being in prison in
solitary confinement for three years and
having no hopes of of resources like not
getting them jobs and having to fight
just to get anything because he had that
that record you,
you get to see that those people you
locked up,
like they have families who were
profoundly affected by everything that
happened and they're gone for these
years and it's just,
it's been a really like
I get like aggressive and when we're
talking about these conversations about
guns and like because those deaths on
that other side of that equation,
that should became real as compete to
me.
Like those are people now that I know
and I know the families of the people
who were on the other side of that and
it's really pushing that.
That's what we,
we,
we need to just really.
Do you guys stop being these tribal
creatures that can only see the,
those fellow humans that are right with
us,
that we associate as being our team.
Like we're all that team and we have.
We have to start having empathy.
For what these things do to other people
and we have to see this.
Cops don't see what their actions do in
order to step up and say,
hey,
we shouldn't be doing this.
We have to get out of this denial bubble
and being involved in the city has just
given me this huge check on,
on all my privileges and everything that
we have.
We don't understand how much advantages
we have in life.
It's ridiculous.
The amount of factors that people have
to fight against that we can't even
register.
And this is all fairly new to you?
Yeah man.
I'm like,
I saw it evidentially,
but to see it in person,
like the work that.
So the photographer,
Devin Allen,
pull up,
he.
He took a picture of my daughter that's
from a protest it's going to be in and
he's doing this project now where he
took the time magazine cover shoot.
So if you ever saw the time magazine
during the uprising or it says 19,
68 and it's crossed out and says 2016,
because he took that picture as a,
as a a young black kid that used to be a
drug dealer who picked up a camera as
his identity project kind of thing.
He didn't know what an identity project
was at that time.
I didn't know what identity project was
at that time,
but he picked up the camera and started
taking pictures and he got that picture
and he's well known now,
but what he did was he took that and now
he used the publicity from all that and
he gets this Devin Allen.
He gets all these.
He started this project that this
community development called Penn north
and he collects cameras now for all
these kids.
Not that he's getting paid.
He collects cameras from around the
world,
brings it in,
and now he runs a thing going through in
sandtown winchester where Freddie gray
was killed.
He takes the,
takes those kids in and teach them
photography and gives them that project
so they have something they can grip
upon on and they have some they can
build up on.
What was sad about that is that this is
Devin who has no resources.
Who is the kid who was a drug dealer who
has everything bothering him and he is
investing in those communities and
trying to provide those things to give
people that,
that identity where they can climb out
of it and they can become.
They can see that vision of being a
contributing member to society and like
that's what we all have to do to give
back these neighborhoods.
That's part of the way of fixing it is
if when people want to help,
you literally have to go down there and
say,
how can I help and do things like that?
Because what revealing is that?
We
all have a skill.
His skill is photography,
but your skill is is hunting or comedy
or talking or however you want to go.
You have these skills that you can teach
and you can pass on so other people can
see an identity.
Some people can,
so some people can do whatever it is.
We all have these skills and that's how
we help.
If you want to be somebody that helps
you cities,
you go down there and you help supply
that identity.
I could just see how many white knights
are saying,
I'm going down to the hood right now and
I'm gonna help gonna just,
well,
I'm fucked up now pants,
but like teeth,
so at Penn north we created this thing
that,
well,
they created this thing called the safe
zone and what that is,
it was all worked out with everybody.
You got to treat everybody like humans.
They worked out with the with the drug
dealers and everything is going on and
they participate in keeping this area of
the city completely safe so that
everybody can come down there and you
would.
If you go to Baltimore,
you want to be a white knight,
you come down and bought bottom and
reach out to an activist and you want to
help.
It's not dangerous.
You will be fired and there are plenty
of people that will help you and guide
you through and what you can do to
contribute to make our society a more
whole place will obviously Baltimore's
in another side of the country.
There's got to be places around here
that,
uh,
need some sort of a similar matter where
you are,
they're all the same.
All these cities are saying they're
facing all the same problems and that
has helped me build this reform
measures.
So my application for Chicago is
completely up.
If you want to pull up my website,
it's Michael Jr net.
Let me ask you this.
Had you gotten the position in Chicago?
You were trying to be the police chief
of police in Chicago,
right?
If you had gotten that position in
Chicago,
what would you do?
What is your idea?
I mean,
I'm sure you have a grand plan,
so it's 38 pages of that on this,
but if you could kind of break it down
for us.
Well,
the first thing we have to do is we have
to give that power away and I think
that's a condition that I have to have
in order to take the job.
Now I have a friend,
uh,
who was,
actually a driver,
Warren Chicago who's a cop and he told
me that what's going on in Chicago was
that they had some pretty high level
drug dealers and gang leaders and then
they caught those guys and imprison them
and when they imprison them and created
a power vacuum and in that power vacuum
over the last few years,
you're seeing significant ramp up in
crime or people try to take over these
areas that were under controlled by
other people similar to what happens
when you see,
when we take over countries like Libya
creates this power vacuum and now you
have a case to almost you say,
well,
it's worse without Gadhafi than it was
with him.
That's sort of what this guy was telling
me about Chicago.
Is that accurate as possible?
Um,
one of the big problems with policing is
we think we
can narrow things down and we can find a
soul causation,
and there just simply isn't any soul
causation.
There has never sold causation in
anything.
When you're dealing with a mass amount
of human beings,
uh,
everybody has different reasons.
You're not going to be able to do
everything perfectly.
And those things can happen perfectly
plausible that it could have happened.
A weird theory that I've started to
recognize is that actually in this
study,
they,
Stefanie Deluca study,
they talk a lot about how these kids are
really more passionate now and they're
exposed to more and you can see that
their work ethic is actually higher than
it was.
We think that they're not working,
but they're achieving things at three to
400 percent of what their parents
achieved.
So these kids are ambitious and so if
you don't have any other options around,
you have a more ambitious population
that's now doing drug dealing and taking
over territory.
What do you mean by they're achieving
things three to 400 percent more than
their ranks.
So you have.
So the average in
the nineties for,
for high school diplomas in college for
residents of a neighborhood like
sandtown or these east and West
Baltimore neighborhoods,
worst that you can imagine in your head
as far as resources go.
They,
these kids are actually achieving a.
So say their,
their parents got 10 percent high school
diplomas.
These guys are getting 40 percent high
school diplomas that our parents were
getting a two percent college degrees.
These guys are at like 25,
30 percent college degrees.
So they're really excelling but they're
not achieving because of all these other
barriers as you know.
Um,
so uh,
a guy,
a black guy with a college degree is
slightly less likely to be employed than
a white guy with a high school diploma
and a criminal record.
So even though they're getting these
promises that if they play by the rules,
then they're get these things at the
end,
just like poor white American,
West Virginia is at.
And w what happens though is there were
being.
They see these examples of with social
media or whatever,
and they're understanding that if they
push hard,
that's the told their push hard and
achieve these things,
then they'll get these rewards,
but they're not getting these rewards.
They're just not there.
So if you have a more ambitious
population and they're turning to drug
dealing and to crime,
well it's just as likely that they're
also more ambitious and dedicated to
their criminal endeavors as they were to
their college achievement.
Right.
So they're better criminals because
they're working hard on schools.
Generation improves,
right?
Yeah.
Is there,
but there.
Is there any improvement in terms of
crime rates?
Well,
I mean there are crime is still
dramatically dropping and we are.
We live in the safest era in human
history right now.
We get caught up in a lot of this and
that that made sure that's a guy who can
say it's a weird argument for the gun
guys are they can just say,
hey,
we are in the safest environment time in
history ever,
so we have to not get caught up in the
fact that,
like you said,
the odds of things happen,
especially compared to the rest of
history because of the sheer numbers
you're dealing with.
Well it would seem like crime,
the percentage of people taking crime if
probably still are about the same and
then or or the amount or the same,
but the population has grown so you have
a lot,
lot less crime percentage wise when you
ever have before,
but if your criminals are that much
better,
but there's still gonna be ambitious,
but are they that much better?
It seems like it's so much easier to
catch them doing something now than ever
before,
other than physically catch them but
mean so much easier to know that that's
really contrary to evidence.
So yeah.
I mean homicide clearance rates from the
eighties were in 80,
90 percent.
Now they're down to 30 to 45 percent.
What does that from?
I think that's from a breakdown of
community relations because we think
that comps,
comps,
comps aren't the answer.
The community is always the answer and
so if you want to solve a crime,
you have to have these good
relationships with your communities in
order for them to even trust you.
Otherwise the streets are just going to
handle it themselves,
right?
If the police don't provide justice will
then they will.
So if he can't turn to the police,
that's another factor you get.
There's tons of factors in here and a
lot of arguments can be made for what it
is,
but the conviction rate has dropped
dramatically and the homicide clearance
rate has dropped dramatically.
Police are not solving crimes at the
rate they used to.
Now when you look at an area like
Chicago that has a lot of violence
connected to the drug war or to the drug
trade,
I should say illegal drug selling,
it's also resources to those.
So the drug trade fulfills in for lack
of priests of very good point.
And that's a point that doesn't get
addressed that often.
Right?
That's a,
that's a very good point.
Now,
what can be done,
what would you have done had you got
that position as well?
So the first thing I have to do here,
here's my model and my fundamental model
is,
is uh,
I think if you had a business and you
have a board,
you know,
yeah,
you have your board of trustees or
whatever you want to call it.
I want to be a civilian leader of the
police department,
like a CEO and I wouldn't have like
officially 49 percent of the power of
the agency.
And then we have like seven people on
this panel who come from the city who
live in these neighborhoods.
I don't,
not sure precisely how we pick them out,
can't appoint them because then they
just become cronies.
Um,
we have some issues with voting that we
may have to work out the details on,
but the,
the ultimate principles that we would
have,
the majority of that board would be from
the poorest of the neighborhoods around.
So you would create a board and what
would,
what would be the picking criteria to
create this board?
Would it be you and other police
officers?
Would be.
This should
be the civilians.
So it has to be the peons pick the
people that are on.
Yeah,
I think we would have to pick them and
stuff.
Steve.
I think we have to have a vote.
This is,
I don't have that fault completely
outright.
Okay.
Uh,
but the majority has to come from the
poor populations covering the base of
whatever is good for the weakest among
us is good for the strongest among us.
And then those boards,
while I run the agency,
I can only argue to them they have 51
percent of the control.
I have all these things I want to argue
for.
But it's fundamentally not my agency.
Okay,
so you would almost give most of the
control to the rest of the people and
they would work with you.
Right.
So there,
I'm the CEO there,
the board,
they're going to come up with that.
We're all going to discuss how we want
to approach issues and I'm going to
bring my science.
I'm going to make my cases as much as I
can on the right way to do things.
But if they want to do things another
way,
it's their agency and that's the.
That's what I would have been done
anywhere.
Not that I'm aware of.
So your,
your idea is so radical and so way out
there and that's part of the problem
with getting people to accept it.
So they would have to take a huge chance
and if it failed it would be their
failure.
Whereas if it fails right now,
here's the trick joke.
Total cop out in a manner because the
failure.
Is it my fault?
Why?
But I'm saying you will be the board's
fault because they have the agency so
interested.
The people are responsible.
They can't bitch at the mayor.
Right,
because they did it.
It's their agency.
It's my job to serve them.
It's not my job to serve a mayor.
Right.
It's my job to serve them and carry out
with.
They want to achieve so I will work at
achieving with they want to achieve and
establishing the milestones and
incentives that they think are better
for their neighborhood because they may
do things which could dramatically have
impacts such as hiring like.
So right now guys won't hire because
they have a drug complaint or something
like that.
Or they have a prior arrest record.
Well,
I think if you get all those poor
neighborhoods together,
they're going to say,
look,
we know that's bullcrap.
The bad arrest doesn't stop you from
being a good cop.
That's ridiculous.
And we can let those people in and they
can take that risk as a whole community.
We can decide these things.
So you're saying make former prisoners
or former criminals turned them into
police officer?
Not that far,
but sure.
I mean some of them.
So the difference between them and me,
we know as the color of my skin and in
the neighborhood I grew up in,
I could have easily had the criminal
record that they have.
Yeah,
I think pretty much anybody could.
Yeah.
Right.
I mean that's.
And that's a hard pill to swallow for
folks who have that pull yourself up by
your bootstraps mentality,
but a lot of who you are and what you
are is luck.
Yep.
Yeah.
Everything important in this country.
One hundred percent shame.
Advantage.
Yeah.
Being born poor in this country is
really way luckier than being born in
the middle class and a lot of other
countries.
So this board that we have,
how long do you think is going to take
before they end the drug war?
It's going to take a day.
Yeah,
but they can't do that because it's a
federal decision.
Essentially.
You're talking about the city of
Chicago,
which not even the state of Illinois.
We can.
You can stop you.
The federal government.
We don't enforce laws.
We don't enforce your law period.
Boy.
Good luck trying to pull that legal.
The feds have to come in and do it
themselves.
The feds would have to come in and
enforce the law.
They didn't do it right.
They were doing in Colorado for a while.
Yeah.
They tried.
That didn't work out well.
Colorado is a perfect example where the
money was so good with the plan that was
initiated where they're making more
money from taxes with marijuana than
they ever did with alcohol,
which is bananas.
Beyond the money.
You have a reduction in crime and in
juvenile usage of marijuana and in drunk
driving.
Yes.
Yeah.
Lowest incidences of drunk driving and
more than a decade.
It's pretty interesting.
It's pretty interesting because it just
shows you that it was predictable.
Yes.
Well,
for people like you or I,
but not for the people that were arguing
against it,
they thought it was going to be chaos
and hippies and they got to like the
town on fire and fuck each other in the
streets and everybody thought it was
gonna be horrible,
but you're talking about a different
drug when you're talking about Chicago,
you're talking about heroin and you're
talking about cocaine.
You're talking about methamphetamine,
you're talking to them about MTMA.
These are different drugs and they have
health consequences as well,
so the legalization or the prohibition
with what they have right now is
obviously not working.
The real problem would be if they
decided to not enforce the drug laws and
they decided to in some way,
you know,
air quotes,
legalize these drugs,
what would take places?
You're going to have some blame be
placed on some deaths on your new laws
and that's going to be paraded out in
front of you.
This is your responsible for the death
of this young girl.
She never tried heroin,
but because it was available at seven
slash 11 and she started snorting it and
then now she's dead.
Somebody's going to get that.
You're going to get that.
That's not the model.
The model.
So you have prohibition and we were like
we were saying earlier,
you know what,
what prohibition does,
it's just the terming that they sell it.
Okay.
It takes the hands and puts it into the
black market.
Yes,
so well yet heroin is a terrible drug,
but what makes heroin so bad is it's
lack of purity and the environment in
which you will you get it.
Well also the addictive properties of
it,
which is why Oxycontin,
even though it's pure and very
measurable,
still has a terrifying effect.
Right,
but what kind of consequences did you
say that was?
He said it was a health consequence.
Well,
it has a criminal consequences will
oxycontin's certainly do.
There's a lot of people that get
arrested for illegally possessing and
selling and distributing.
It's a huge issue.
Right,
right,
right.
Understand,
I mean the drugs period of health issue.
Yes.
There are not a criminal issue.
They're not a prison issue.
There are public health issue,
so we treat that with health
professionals,
not with jail cells in and police.
So while May,
it's not like I'm saying that the drug
dealers can go out there and just deal
it.
That's not what I want.
I want a doctor handling everything.
I want it moved into just no different
than alcohol.
Well,
the problem with the doctor handling is
that's what happened in Florida and what
happened in Florida.
They developed this environment where
they didn't have a database where they,
the doctors and the pharmaceutical
companies were all in cahoots and they
said,
look,
let's just sell the shit out of this.
And the statistics were staggering.
There was more prescriptions for
Oxycontin's and opiate pain killers in
Florida than the rest of the United
States combined.
I know that is nuts,
but what were they doing with it?
They were selling it.
They were taking it or selling it
illegal around the oxycontin express a
documentary that showed that these
people were bringing it from Florida,
upstate into Georgia and Kentucky,
but they don't have that market.
They wouldn't have that market in
Chicago with me.
Right.
So Florida couldn't do that because you
wouldn't have a market to sell it in.
So the only reason that that's
the only reason take away the market.
The only reason that exists is because
they can go sell it on the black market.
So if you take away the black market as
being the distributor then so you would
allow people to just sell it?
No,
no,
no.
Only doctors.
Only doctors for those certain drugs
first.
So cannabis or something like that.
We need to put in a model similar and we
have things in Portugal or what Portugal
does,
they just decriminalize it so they don't
put people in prison cells for
possessing it.
And if you want to still go after the
dealers as a half measure,
that's a half measure I'd have to
swallow that I don't completely believe
in,
but we can work those things out.
Me and you,
if you're the panel and I'm the CEO,
we can work these things out and come to
a position where we're like,
okay,
let's try this and if you,
if you want to go by the incremental
ism,
then we see that that's okay.
Just like in Colorado already has proven
that the cannabis model is fine,
right?
So we can start with the cannabis model
and move that in and then we can say,
alright,
well let's put cocaine into this model
and then see how that goes.
If you want to be incremental about it,
I'm fine with that.
The cannabis model,
the problem is the innocuous negative
effects are just.
It's just really the.
There's almost nothing.
There's so little to fall on that,
but we don't make that case with alcohol
or tobacco.
That's true.
But tobacco is not a good one because
it's a long,
slow death as long as it's.
As long as it takes a long time.
Yeah,
we can accept me.
And that's how we at it.
It's almost like what
we're doing cost.
The costs of tobacco is extraordinary on
our healthcare system.
Oh no doubt about it.
Right.
And when you think about alcohol,
that's the real argument because alcohol
is one of the easiest drugs to kill
yourself with people.
I think there's a staggering number.
I think it's like 10,000 people drink
themselves to death every year just in
this country,
which is really pretty shocking and that
doesn't count drunk driving,
alcohol related violence and all the
other things that go along with it.
The problem with making heroin or
cocaine with decriminalizing it,
but then go after going after the
dealers is then,
well,
okay,
if these people get hooked on it,
where are they going to get it?
Then
they have to go to a doctor.
I mean it's just the way we have to do
it,
so it is not treatment,
but it then becomes exactly like
Florida.
But remember what we do know.
We do know that every million spent when
the demand side reduces by 100
kilograms,
right?
So we have to keep focusing on
education.
I don't if those people that got hooked
on oxy became heroin addicts,
if they had the education that this was
the path they were going to go,
one,
you got to believe that a significant
percentage of them wouldn't have gone
that path.
Yeah,
I mean now we're all aware of it and I
know plenty of people now that the
doctor says here's some oxy,
and they're like,
no,
give me something else.
What do you do with people that are so
fucking dumb?
They just want to party.
And you got some of those things that a
little bit harder,
just like you gotta let them drink
themselves to death.
And what are you gonna do?
Ooh,
that's a hard pill for people to
swallow,
but it's better than putting them in a
prison cell.
Yes,
it is.
What have you got going on,
Jeremy?
Drinking too much.
Excessive alcohol use lead to
approximately 88,000 deaths and two
point $5,
million years of potential life lost.
What does that mean?
I guess like you're saying,
drunk driving now in the United States,
two point 5 million years of people's
lives.
That's a weird fucking statistic from
2006 to 2010 shortening the lives of
those who died by an average of 30
years.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it definitely,
okay,
that's life lost,
meaning you,
um,
you drink yourself into an early grave,
that's a weird thing to argue,
but the 88,000 deaths over a period of a
four years,
that's,
that's harsh.
But that's what we were saying in.
It's essentially a little bit more than
what I was saying.
We also know the solution to that or a
solution to a significant portion of
that education,
education and legalization of marijuana.
Yeah.
Empirically know,
we know those will improve the
situations,
but instead we continue to do things we
know don't work.
Right?
So I'm a scientist.
I am interested in what works.
I'm going to argue for what works and
someone else can argue against it,
but that's going to be what I continue
to argue for.
I don't have an emotional position on I,
I'm,
I'm
following the evidence,
right?
We,
we literally know these things.
Not only that,
there's also a drug that is illegal,
that has a significant impact on
addiction.
It's called Ibogaine and Ibogaine,
which is being used in treatment
facilities all throughout South America
and Mexico with massive positive
results,
uh,
is illegal in this country for no
apparent reason.
And I've heard that the people that do
that are just like,
that's it.
As soon as they take it to like,
I don't want it anymore to carry out.
Well,
it rewires the way your brain
concentrates or the way your brain is
affected by these substances.
It rewires addiction.
I mean,
I'm not the one to explain how it works.
Aubrey will be in this week and he'll
probably be the best person to do it.
Got Another one.
This is from the Washington Post.
This statistic of how many Americans
drink every week.
So he's going to read that one little
thing right here,
up to 10 drinks per day up to the top 10
percent of American adults.
Twenty $4 million of them consume an
average of 74 drinks per week.
Or a little more than 10 drinks per day.
Holy Shit.
Compared to about 30 percent that don't
drink at all.
Holy Shit.
How many of them are doing that?
Because cannabis is illegal.
Well,
I'm sure quite a few,
but quite a few,
you know,
look,
there's a lot.
Obviously,
you know,
I'm a marijuana enthusiastic.
I love it.
I think it's awesome.
I want to spark one up right now
thinking about it.
I'm a big fan,
uh,
but some people don't like it.
They don't like the abrasively
introspective properties of cannabis.
They don't like the paranoia.
They don't like all the vulnerability
feelings that you get from it.
I liked those.
Those are good for me.
My personality.
I have to type a aggressive,
you know,
I'm good with a substance,
a compound,
a that sort of like calms that down and
mellows me out.
It gives me a different perspective.
I enjoy it and I think it's good for
people.
I really do.
I think a lot of the things that people
associate with a negative aspect of
cannabis to particularly the paranoia.
I think that's good.
I really do.
I do.
I think we need to feel more vulnerable.
I think more feeling more vulnerable is
better for you because it enhances a
sense of community and friendship and
love and a lot of ways and it it,
it bonds people together.
I think this idea that you're an
individual,
that you are a,
you know,
you were alone,
rebel out there kicking ass and taking
names.
You're doing it all by yourself.
That's all eroded instantaneously by
cannabis.
It just said,
no,
no.
You're a talking monkey on a spinning
ball flying through infinity fuckhead
and you're like,
ah,
I'm fucking scared.
I'm going to die some day and I couldn't
agree with you more.
I think those are really important
qualities for our entire race.
The human race.
I think they.
It enhances more community feelings and
thoughts and I think that's the opposite
of with some drugs like stimulants,
do.
Stimulants.
I've always avoided stimulants.
I'm not a fan other than coffee.
I've never really tried them,
but I've seen their effect on other
people and I've read about their effects
and it's not what I'm looking for.
I don't want to be cocky.
I don't.
Yeah.
I'm trying to fight whatever urges my
body and my personality have to sort of
lean towards that,
but I think that people that get
involved with speed,
people to get involved with coke,
those are people that are like unduly
confident.
It's A.
I think there's a bad drug for society
and it's A.
It's a drug that is very selfish in its
effects like the,
the,
the impact that it has on people's.
They become really selfish and nasty and
I'm not into that.
I think that alcohol for some people is
a,
is an escape from the reality that they
find themselves in and they don't know
how to get out and I think education
like we were talking about before,
allowing people to have access to the
stories and the,
the,
the consequences that other people have
experienced from taking that drug will
help them.
What kept me from doing coke when I was
young was having friends that had
problems with it and that educated me.
I was like,
fuck,
I don't want to be like that guy.
I don't want to have that happen to me.
I see what's happening to this person.
Some people don't get exposed to that
and instead before they know it,
they're already in it.
They're trying it when they're 15,
next thing you know,
they like it too much.
Next thing you know they're looking
forward to doing that because it
provides some sort of an escape from the
pressure of the consequences of pursuing
a dream,
of chasing down life or of not having a
direction.
That's another one.
Not having,
like you were saying,
the the identity that you're focusing
on,
whether it's this gentleman that was a
photographer or someone else that wants
to be an athlete or someone else who
wants to be an author.
Whatever it is,
it's one thing that you're chasing.
If you don't have that thing,
this,
this sort of futility of life is very
overwhelming to some people and they
want to escape that pain.
The pain of not knowing what the fuck
you're doing and I think some of that I
just going to go way out there,
but I think some of that goes back to
the hunter gatherer genes that we have
in our.
In our own bodies,
I think we're in a lot of ways were a
prisoner to the needs of the past and
the needs of the past where we were very
goal oriented.
You have to go out there,
you know,
to pick the right amount of foods that
you could eat.
You have to hunt the animals or catch
the fish and that was the goal and we
were very goal oriented in that way.
You had to go out there and do that.
You had to work hard and then through
those goals you get this feeling of
satisfaction when you're just getting
food and it's.
It comes to you.
When your job involves doing something
that's not rewarding in any way,
shape or form and this is what you have
to do to get that food.
You've sort of taken out all the natural
reward systems that our bodies are
designed to sort of gravitate towards
and unless you find a passion,
unless you find an art or craft or a
trade or some sort of a thing that
excites you mentally and stimulates your
creativity and stimulates your ambition,
your left lost.
And there's a lot of people that are
just left last and unfulfilled and
unsatisfied and I think those types of
people gravitate towards alcohol and a
lot of other drugs as an escape.
And that's a part of the problem with
society was how we view drugs.
We view drugs as an escape rather than
an enhancement or rather than a
perspective and an enhancer,
we,
we view them as,
oh,
this guy's weak.
He needs a drug.
Yeah.
I,
I think,
I think you're spot on.
I don't know how you could argue that,
but it,
it ties all together.
So I know you sound like liberal.
I mean you plurally sound like liberal
hippies when you like start putting all
these things together,
but these things really do tie in
together so you have the alcoholism
because people aren't finding their
identities.
So we should be doing things.
So like help people create identities if
we want a safer environment.
Right?
So it's not about taking those people
and put them into prisons as you
articulate it.
It's about finding that passion or
educating them to do something.
And,
and so if you want to help or police or
whoever want to help,
you have to be addressing those kinds of
issues.
And I think so people,
one thing we've noticed throughout,
throughout human history is that when
things are really tough and there's no
resources,
right,
the leaders of the oppressed,
like so say it's really easy to use,
um,
the black segregated neighborhoods right
now,
you know,
it's easy example.
Well,
it's not just easy as an example.
So it's a very good exists.
So the masculine members of a society
that can't achieve something,
they turned to making everything about
masculinity and dominance and accepting
of the,
of that lower realm,
and they start to treat,
uh,
intelligence and education as a feminine
or,
or weak.
And,
and so you have that,
that,
that plays into the culture of where you
have the guns and everybody has to know
the disrespecting culture.
And this is my corner kind of culture.
So we have those kinds of benefits that
are a factor also in,
in leveling the playing field for
everybody and contributing.
So one of the things that we're doing
right now is we're building a studio
like this in Baltimore and it's called a
radio revolver and that'll be my
shameless plug.
So go fund me Radio Revolver and we
still need a few more thousand dollars
to fix everything up.
What are you doing?
So we are making it.
So we have a video recording,
like skype session,
have the podcasts,
the whole setup like this for with eight
Mike's.
And we're trying to set everything up.
We have local artists that are painting
everything in the inside.
Let me stop right now.
A people are going to talk over each
other.
Never have more than two.
Okay?
Okay.
We've made that mistake many times.
We have these fight companions with four
and they're my best friends and we're
all fucking yelling over each other.
I try to watch one of those the other
day I was like,
Oh my God,
I'm getting a headache.
Sometimes those are pretty fun.
Uh,
we get hammered,
they're ridiculous.
But I'm just saying if you have eight
people to really.
It's like you ever heard that expression
one?
Um,
one boy,
one boys work,
two boys,
half boys work,
meaning that like if you have two young
kids together and they're working on
something,
they're just going to start talking shit
and it's not going to get done.
And if you have one kid that's digging a
hole,
he's going to actually get that job
done.
But if you have like four people,
nothing gets done and that,
that's really the case.
I'm definitely going to write that down.
You just ate people's to money.
So one of the people that I met was a,
if you ever heard serial podcast,
Jamie,
do you know that?
Sure.
So,
okay,
that's it.
No,
I don't,
but I'm aware of it.
The first season is about it,
not salaried,
who was wrongfully imprisoned right now
in Maryland and still,
right.
So his Bentley wrongfully,
I think so w.
well.
So regardless of whether you get a point
of whether he did or not,
I'm honestly unaware of the case.
What,
what was he accused of?
So,
uh,
in high school at 17 of murdering his ex
girlfriend,
a classmate at woodland high high
school.
Um,
the evidence,
regardless of whether somebody was to
argue about whether he actually did it
or not,
the evidence is extremely clear that you
do not have the evidence to put this
individual in jail,
period.
It's not there.
His best friend is the partner with me
for radio revolver and we ended up being
connected for it because I helped out on
that podcast for awhile and you know,
we've,
we have this community that we formed
now,
so he's helping me with this and this is
an example of how you use your privilege
and sensationalism.
So I was sensationalized by what I said
before,
right by the,
the cops hitting people and all the
things they did and probably what I'm
most proud of is that I instantly
switched from that sensationalism to how
we fix things and what the reform
measures are.
And we don't even talk about that
sensationalism anymore.
But don't you think the sensationalism
was important because it,
it brought you to people.
It's critical.
Yeah.
Right.
So the successfulness of turning that
around into something productive.
Part of that is this radio revolver.
So if you have privilege and you have an
advantage or something which you have to
do is you have to build platforms for
other people,
build structure so that other people can
rise not just for yourself.
And the idea behind this is we'll,
we'll have the network.
So it ended up being turnkey.
It's in a room that anybody can come in
at anytime and if the community,
the community members,
we already have them tied in.
I think we're,
we're going to have a problem with who
we cut out versus we're going to let in
and we're in creating the entire
infrastructure under one umbrella for
them to come in and have their voices
heard and get their message out there.
They can build a podcast,
they can build a video like a TV show
type of thing and none of this is ever
going to cost any of them anything.
And if they succeed and we ended up
getting to a point where we're in the
red,
then we just start taking all the
profits and distributed out to whoever
you know,
proportionately has the podcast that
does the best or whatever.
But the point of that is if you have
that,
that is gonna enable at least 10 to 20
identity projects so somebody else has
to come in and do the other end of that,
take whatever you have and do that same
kind of thing.
If you have money,
then we can take the money and we can do
something good with that.
If you have that skill,
then you can come into a place like
we're building or a place like penn
north and pass that on.
That is really what we have to do as an
individual level.
And if so,
I would always love it if people would
help me out with radio revolver so we
can get that finished.
So you're.
What you're going to do is
put together a podcast and through that
podcast you're gonna have people tell
their stories.
You're going to expose the world to the
plight of these inner cities and the
positive stories about people rising out
of them and your friend,
the photographer,
and a bunch of other people that you can
get exposed to.
So I think one of the most important
things for a young person is to believe
that they can somehow or another be
successful.
I remember when when I was young,
we were poor.
I always identified with being a poor
person and I never thought that I would
be anything other than a poor person
because I would see people that were
wealthy and they've always felt so
different than me.
They always felt so anyone who is
successful,
I shouldn't even just say wealthy,
just a normal person like you know,
like someone who lives in a normal house
with a garage and that you know,
like,
wow,
that's a,
that's a person that the America aspires
to.
They feel different than you if you're
from a broken home,
if you're from poverty.
And in my case obviously was nothing in
comparison to the extreme poverty that a
lot of people face,
but I still remember feeling really
insecure and really I'm disconnected
from successful people.
I think that mindset is a very difficult
to overcome.
It's very difficult.
It's very difficult to believe that you
can achieve something.
can rise from no matter where you are,
if you continue to work and you continue
to pursue your goals and you can avoid
all the pitfalls of the negative aspects
of society,
you can do better,
you can do better and you can feel
satisfied in that and to give people
these opportunities to see people who
have done the very thing that you're
aspiring to do is massively beneficial
because it gives them sort of a like a
little bit of a blueprint.
Yeah,
I mean and that's exactly the point
would say these things.
I mean you may as well just be me saying
that I,
I agree with you completely.
I mean it's critically important that we
set these up for people and they can do
that and they do that now.
It just reminds me when you said that,
like they come up to my house and like
that's like success to them and that's
what I am.
I'm a dude with a single family home in
a garage and not really.
Yeah.
I don't have any money,
but it's honestly all anybody ever
really needs and wants.
I mean,
you can get a giant ass fucking house,
but let me tell you something.
At the end of the day,
it's just your house.
You know that.
It's just where you live.
Is it comfortable?
Is it safe?
Yeah.
That's what everybody really wants.
Yeah,
definitely.
That's really what it's all about and
one of the most positive aspects of
doing this podcast is running into
people that I've met that said,
hey man,
I've been doing standup comedy for three
years now.
I'm actually a working comedian.
I did it from listening to your podcast.
I knew that I could do it because you
told me that anybody can do it if you
just try that you,
I,
I used to suck and I tell everybody I
always,
I was fucking terrible,
but you keep chipping away at it and
she's listening to your recordings and
all that jazz.
I've run into a million fucking people
that have started doing Jujitsu now.
I mean it's.
I mean,
it's not a million,
but it's not countable anymore.
I've ran into so many people that,
hey man,
I just got my purple belt,
started listening to you guys.
You know,
now I'm competing my lifestyle.
So much healthier.
I eat cleaner,
everything's better.
My life is just.
I used to be depressed.
It's so much more positive,
so I take great,
satisfied.
I would say private.
It's not the right word.
It's a great satisfaction.
It feels awesome to talk to people that
have looked at this little sort of
blueprint that I've laid out and said,
look,
anybody can do this.
You can do this,
like whatever patterns that you're
following because the people that you're
around are in these negative patterns.
You don't have to follow those patterns.
It's one of the beautiful things about
social media and the beautiful things
about the internet.
As you can kind of choose what you
follow.
I mean,
you could go and just follow negative
stuff all day long.
You could concentrate on negative
bullshit and you could be one of those
people who goes on twitter and just
bombs on people and Shits on people all
day and that's going to be your point of
focus,
but you're not gonna get any better at
anything doing that.
You're not going to have a better life.
You're not going to feel better.
You're not going to be happier.
You're not going to spread any,
any,
anything beneficial,
anything positive to anybody,
but you can take a choice to not do that
and a lot of times you need to see that
someone else has done that in order to
help you do it.
I hope you're inspiring others because
you're kind of inspired me right now
like thinking about how many identity
projects that you lead even though they
were maybe not even been obvious to you
because you've gone and use this
platform to do these things,
I think is highly honorable of you that
you use this platform so that I can talk
about these things about blm black lives
matter and about police reform and
things like that.
That's like the typical like prototype
of what what we're talking about you,
you were great work,
but by doing that,
well it's helping me a lot too.
Honestly.
I mean I think everyone's life is a
constant journey.
You're,
you're.
I mean unless you just stay sedentary
and you don't go anywhere and you don't
take it.
Any new data your,
your life is all about reevaluating the
way you think or evaluating it or
enhancing it or adding to it or removing
some negative aspects of the way you
think and one of the best ways that I've
found to do that as exposed myself to
interesting people like you or like any
of the other people that I've had the
pleasure and the opportunity to,
to talk to on this podcast.
You get this.
I mean I've had three hour conversations
with 800 fucking will not 800 people,
but it's 800 times.
And having those kinds of conversations,
it forces you to think it forces you to.
Like.
One of the things that Eddie Wong was
saying that really resonated with me is
that he likes to write.
He writes every day and one of the
things that the reasons why he likes to
write is it makes him solidify his own
thoughts.
He thinks about his own thoughts and it
really sort of like it.
It allows him to really,
really kind of examined them and go in
depth as to how he really truly feels
about something and really get a cleaner
perspective instead of just,
I think a lot of people,
me included,
I've been guilty of this in the past.
We operate on momentum.
We just get a path.
You're on it for some whatever reason
and then just sort of stuck and you just
sort of behave that way and think that
way and you don't ever examine it and
writing allows you to really pause and
look at that.
Podcasting does the same and a lot of
ways.
It allows me to pause and really think
about some of the things that I've
attached myself to or not attached
myself.
And it's recorded.
We're going to be able to
recorded the shits live,
right?
So it is,
whew,
it is you,
it's you.
It's who you are,
you know,
and all for good or for bad,
and you get to see negative aspects of
the way you think and the way you talk
and then you get to see the
repercussions of those and you get to
consider like,
why did I think that way?
Was I just,
was it just a knee jerk reaction?
Was it just was tired that day?
Was I not respecting the medium?
Was I not respecting the power of these
thoughts and these conversations?
Most likely a combination of all those
things,
but through the personal growth that is
a been afforded me by the podcast.
It's helped me in as much as it's helped
anybody.
It's,
it's helped me tremendously and having
these kinds of conversations with people
like you are a giant part of that.
Oh thanks.
I don't know how to take the stuff that
relates to that,
but I don't know.
I can't.
I can't sing your praises enough for
having that kind of mentality and being
the Alpha male that is vulnerable and
lets other people see that it's okay
though.
Those things are important.
Uh,
it's okay for,
for the tough guys,
is that to let their guard down and be
introspective and to be people that are
willing to help and reach out.
It's entirely admirable.
I'm like,
chunk is another person that I've gotten
closer.
You've had him on here and say his name.
Right.
I'm glad that you say right.
He,
he,
he jokes about that.
How like people that have known him his
whole life,
right?
It's Jank,
right,
Jay,
right.
Yeah.
Well the young Turks with what they've
done is they've developed a sort of
alternative media platform that's
outside of the mainstream media,
but it has arguably as much impact when
you look at what they've been able to do
on youtube and they're one of many,
you know,
there's a lot of people that are pushing
unusual ideas on the internet.
Um,
the amazing atheist is another one.
I've really enjoyed a lot of his stuff
lately.
Tj is a fucking really bright guy and he
puts out some really interesting,
well thought out videos.
You GotTa pee or something.
That was,
that was giving them that address.
Just talking about we got James Jesus.
He's good.
I got to go see him this week.
Just don't call it chain.
So,
uh,
putting our money where our mouth is.
We got locked up this year.
You guys got locked up in DC?
Arrest it.
Have you got the pictures of it?
Jack did too.
He got arrested.
He got arrested together.
Do you arrested for,
for sitting in,
for democracy spring.
Is that a serving or protecting?
Um,
how does that work?
Would have been serving.
Do you?
Um,
do you,
will you?
Yeah.
Do you guys get 'em of rec arrest
records for that?
Okay.
So you still get in Canada?
I guess Jake does a real legit.
I just record so I fought it because it
was in DC.
Right,
because it close to you close to me.
I can find it.
So they ended up dropping the charges on
me.
Okay.
Um,
we had got a phone call that there was
no way they were going to put me a
chance to speak in a,
a record it public forum.
What's that?
They said they dropped my case.
What were you protesting?
The get money out of politics.
So I'm,
we're not people like jake and I are not
just talking out of our asses on this,
we,
we mean it.
And so we went and we participated in
the march and got arrested in Washington
DC.
Why did you get arrested for,
what was the charge?
Like loitering or some bullshit?
Uh,
I forget how they completely worded it.
And so it's because you were protesting
in a public area and blocking traffic or
something.
That's what they said.
There was nobody trying to go into or
out of the capital and that's where we
were.
Right.
But they wouldn't be able to if they did
want to because you guys were away.
Oh,
okay.
Well that's kind of loitering,
right?
But that does get attention to what
you're trying to.
The largest mass arrests in DC history.
It was like a 200 and some of us that
got arrested the first day.
Wow.
Like 450 overall.
Um,
so we have,
we have some good pictures of it.
If Jamie that website's not working.
I don't know,
it's maywood photography.
M a e l w o o d o,
that's my phone.
I'm sorry.
Um,
so what were the cops like when they
arrested him?
They're like,
I'm sorry,
this is bullshit.
We got a restaurant or they're being
dicks.
Some of them are still being text,
unbelievably considering it was a.
When you see this crowd,
so they were treating you like an actual
criminal even though it's pretty obvious
you're trying to campaign against
something that's something that nobody
really thinks is a good thing.
Money and politics.
The lieutenant said,
Hey,
I'm glad that you guys are out here
doing that.
Really,
the lieutenant said,
Holy Shit,
these are capital police.
Um,
I've sang their praises before,
but they don't face a lot.
So they hadn't.
There's,
there's jake.
So that's a captain,
Ray Lewis.
He also was arrested and he wears his
uniform,
do it.
He's a retired Philadelphia,
a police officer,
and he wore his uniform and he got
arrested in his uniform and they took it
sign and threw it away and they charged
it.
Say,
what does the sign say?
Massive civil scratched out.
Disobedience is next.
Warning.
Massive disobedience is next.
What does that mean?
Well,
because I'm assuming what he means by
this,
but right now the disobedience is civil,
right?
So we're protesting.
We were doing things like this,
but like I'm flabbergasted that the
black community in these neighborhoods
hasn't really said enough,
is enough yet.
Like the idea that we,
they have children and family members
dying in the streets.
They're probably scared to get arrested,
man.
They are.
But I just,
there's a breaking point that's coming
and that's,
that's what he's trying to say is.
And what I've tried to don't scroll.
What's up with the dudes with the nose
ring?
The fuck's going on there?
Oh,
he's a,
uh,
he's an actual,
I can't remember tribe he's from and he
participates in a lot of these things
and what to do with the Musket.
Scroll down there.
J side.
I don't know what that looks like.
A musket when I was only seeing the tip
of it.
What?
The tip of the.
I thought it was a just a musket tip.
Never just a tip.
Don't fall.
So,
uh,
I don't know what you're saying.
A dollars in.
What does that scroll down?
Dollars in politics.
Grass ranch out,
so it's essentially just a bunch of
people standing in a place where the
government didn't think you should be
able to stand.
Right.
And we kinda keep drawing attention to
this money in politics because I really
think that's the root.
It's the root of everything.
We can't end the drug war because of
this.
We can't move anything forward.
We can't do police reform because of
this democracy spring.
They're calling it.
Yeah.
That was the one day.
Different groups,
different days.
So it was a whole week long.
This was the first day was the biggest
day and you'll have me in handcuffs at
the end eventually.
But.
So how long did you have to stay in jail
for the night?
Oh no annoying.
Well it wasn't snoring.
It wasn't a real jail.
There were so many people that it was
just like they were keeping us in like
animal pens and felt like a.
So we would just be like panned off.
Like they I think took us to a different
place and had like a,
like fences,
like portable fences and they will punch
you like.
So it's not like you really couldn't get
out,
you could get out if you want it to.
I guess I could have if I really wanted
to,
I wasn't going to go for an escape
charge.
This is so silly,
but seems like so the dumb way to handle
it.
Everybody's smiling,
getting handcuffed as you see.
It's a pretty white crowd.
Oh,
it's fun.
So I think that helps on the way the
police act.
Like some people just psyched to be
hanging out with Cenk.
Yeah,
no.
Weird.
So that's an example of another thing.
I mean you can go and you can
participate in these things.
So if that is a passion of yours,
I think that's another identity thing
that we have.
You can,
you can go and see these groups.
There's all these groups out there and
like you're saying that these people
feel lost and they're turning to two
other things.
But we have all these things out there
and if you don't have one,
create one.
There are out there like the tyt family,
like your family,
like black lives matter.
We have tons of of movements going on
that,
that you can do something positive with
no matter who you are.
Okay.
So tell us one more time,
what's the name of this podcast and when
do you hope this thing's going to start?
So name of the podcast or the radio
right now it's called,
it's called radio revolver.
And that's just the umbrella.
Why Radio Revolver about guns?
Yeah,
we finally had that place.
So I revolving door,
like a prison cell is how I envisioned
it.
They wanted to use like a gun logo and I
was like,
no,
you can't do that radio revolver,
podcast network.
Right.
So here's some of the friends that I've
made that are activists around and
there's definitely be ones that are in
there.
We were doing a serial show and we took
that picture and so the donating is for
equipment and for rental space.
The space was donated by sod.
It's basement of his house all blocked
off and done.
So that's not an issue.
We have that done.
Um,
what do you need to.
We're still just getting the last bit of
equipment.
We have some of the local artists
painting the walls now.
Oh Great.
And so we're close.
We don't,
I mean like maybe $3,000 and I'm a and w
we're were set.
Well let me know when you guys launch
and I will absolutely tweeted out and
let everybody be aware of it.
The first one is going to.
So again,
part of the part of the thing that we're
going to do is we take advantage of,
of me right in the publicity.
So the first one is going to be a joint
project with undisclosed who is a
affiliate with serial story and all and
that one's going to be a misconduct
which is going to be one of the series
we have.
So there's gonna be multiple podcasts.
Okay.
One of them is going to be misconduct
and then you'll have like the
photography warner,
you have a public health one like doc
large brown is,
is going to do a public health one.
So you're essentially building a whole
whole station.
Okay,
great.
Right.
And so everybody that wants in,
you know,
as long as you learn what you're doing
and everything,
you will be able to have your voice
heard in whichever manner you want.
That's a great idea because you know,
this is one of the easiest ways to get a
message out and the message that you
know,
you,
when you hear someone talk man,
and you hear their words and you get to
know them through the hours and hours of
conversations,
you get to know him in a really deep,
intimate way.
You're assigning example ivy,
you walk around and everybody to know
you.
People hugged me.
I don't even know my baby.
What's up?
Right?
So the first one's called misconduct,
which is going to be a series and I'm
going to do the first one and it's going
to be the killing of Freddie Gray.
So we're.
What we're going to do for that is go
through the story.
And when we first go through the story,
the first episode will start and we
start telling what happened.
Like,
so these cops are in this neighborhood
and Freddie gray is in this.
And then we go,
but wait,
why does it look this way?
And then so like somebody like doc brown
will come in and we're go over through
the history of segregation,
how the neighborhoods are formed,
the way they are,
why the cops were all white,
why the citizens are all black,
and we'll go explain that story and then
the next episode I'll start over again,
start telling the story and when we hit
the next hurdle,
which will be something like,
well,
why are they going after him for the
drugs and why are they chasing him?
So,
so then we're breakdown the history of
the laws and why the why that is done
the way it is.
What policing philosophies of led to
this.
Until we finish out the entire story and
everybody can understand the nuance to
what happened behind the murder of
Freddie Gray.
All right man.
Well listen,
thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
And we'll definitely want to do that
thing with my friend Justin.
Yep.
If he's down,
we'll have a fucking gun control hoedown
down up in this bitch.
I'm certainly.
We'll definitely promote your podcast as
soon as it launches.
Radio revolve,
revolver,
so go to go fund me.com.
Forward Slash Radio revolver.
Go and contribute and you can follow
Michael on twitter.
Michael Wood Jr.
Is that what it is on twitter?
Michael?
A wood jr on twitter.
Thank you brother.
I really appreciate it.
Good seeing you again.
We'll do it again.
Yes,
definitely.
Thank you folks.
We'll be back soon.
Bye.
Mama.